STREAMING --
WELCOME THIS IS THE FIRST OF
WHAT WE EXPECT TO BE TWO
HEARINGS OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE
ON SMALL BUSINESS AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAURA
FRIEDMAN FROM THE FORTY THIRD
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT AND I'M JOINED
TODAY BY MY COLLEAGUE ELOISE
REYES.
WHO IS --
I'M ONE OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M AFTER THIS HEARING WE'RE
GOING TO BE DOING A SIMILAR
HEARING IN THE CENTRAL COAST --
AND WERE MORE THAN HAPPY TO GO
TO OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE IF
THEY'RE INTERESTED IN HAVING US
AS WELL.
OF THE REASON THAT I HAD ASKED
YOU CAN --
TO HOWEVER A COMMITTEE ON SMALL
BUSINESS IS BECAUSE AFTER BEING
IN SACRAMENTO FOR ALMOST TWO
YEARS I'M IN MY FIRST TERM.
I NOTICE THAT LARGE BUSINESSES
HAVE A VERY LARGE VOICE --
WHATEVER WHERE ARE LOOKING TO
ADOPT A NEW REGULATION --
WE HEAR A LOT FROM OUR LARGER
BUSINESSES.
BUT WE DON'T HEAR AS MUCH FROM
THE SMALL BUSINESSES IT'S HARD
FOR THEM TO HAVE A UNIFIED VOICE.
WHEN IT COMES TO STATEWIDE
POLICY [INAUDIBLE]
AND WHAT'S [INAUDIBLE]
EASY. TO COMPLY WITH FOR VERY
LARGE BUSINESS.
CAN BE A HUGE HURDLE FOR SMALLER
BUSINESS.
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES WE ALWAYS
HEAR THE BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY
AND THAT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT WE SPEND
ENOUGH TIME REALLY LISTENING TO
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES. FOR ONE
THING THE LANDSCAPE OF SMALL
BUSINESSES HAS CHANGED OVER THE
YEARS -- I
THINK WE NEED TO BEGIN TO THINK
OF OUR SMALLEST ENTREPRENEURS
THE ONE PERSON TO PERSON
BUSINESSES AS ALSO BEING
IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTORS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES.
AND THEY ARE AFFECTED VERY VERY
DIFFERENTLY TO LICENSURE
REGULATION TAX STRUCTURE ALL OF
THE THINGS THAT AFFECT BUSINESS
VERY DIFFERENTLY THAN LARGE
BUSINESSES AND EVEN FOR A LARGER
SMALL BUSINESSES.
SO TODAY WHAT I WANT TO TRY TO
DO IS TO HEAR FROM A LOT OF THE
EXPERTS FROM FROM SOME FROM SOME
OF OUR LOCAL SMALL BUSINESSES AS
WELL. TO HERE ABOUT THEIR ISSUES
ABOUT BARRIERS IN OPPORTUNITIES
FROM SACRAMENTO.
SO THAT WE CAN BETTER CRAFT
LEGISLATION AND BE MORE
SENSITIVE TO THE NEEDS OF OUR
BUSINESSES.
NOW I KNOW THAT DIFFERENT
BUSINESS SECTORS HAVE VERY
DIFFERENT NEEDS WHAT'S A BIG
ISSUE TO A MASSAGE PARLOR MIGHT
BE COMPLETE NON ISSUE TO A
RESTAURANT.
SO WHAT I'M HOPING TO DO IS TO
FIND COMMONALITY IF NOT ACROSS
THE ENTIRE SPECTRUM OF SMALL
BUSINESS AT LEAST FROM A LARGE
BUSINESS SECTORS.
AND IT'S MY HOPE THAT AT THE END
OF THESE HEARINGS THAT MISS
RANSOM MYSELF AND MAYBE SOME OF
THE OTHER MEMBERS FROM NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE'RE GOING TO BE.
PAID IN THE NEXT HEARING.
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION PERHAPS
BASED ON WHAT WE HEAR OR AT THE
VERY LEAST ARE MORE SENSITIVE
I'M AS WE HEAR BILLS HONEST
DIFFERENT ISSUES COME IN FRONT
OF US.
SO WITH THAT I'M GONNA TURN TO
ON THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M LOOK
REYES TO SEE IF SHE HAS ANY
OPENING COMMENTS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH IT'S SUCH AN
HONOR TO BE HERE WITH YOU IN
GLENDALE I'VE HEARD ABOUT
GLENDALE BECAUSE YOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
SPEAKS OF GLENDALE ALL THE TIME
AS IF THERE WERE NO OTHER CITIES.
IN THE ENTIRE STATE OF ARNOLD IS
ALSO BURBANK LOCKING OUT AND LOS
ANGELES [INAUDIBLE]
VERY.
YEAH THE FORMER MAYOR STORES I
WAS [INAUDIBLE]
SEE.
THE PHOTO OF MY COLLEAGUE THERE.
SMALL BUSINESS IS WITHOUT A
DOUBT ARE SO IMPORTANT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES SO IMPORTANT.
A THAT I WAS A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS AYE --
WAS LIGHTS CAME OUT AS AN
ATTORNEY I JOIN THE LAW FIRM AND
THEN WENT OUT ON MY OWN AND
FOUND OUT THAT.
WHEN I OPENED MY OFFICE I WAS
THE FIRST LATINA EVER TO OPEN UP
A SMALL BUSINESS IN THE ENTIRE
INLAND EMPIRE SOMEBODY DEAN ON
RIVERSIDE COUNTIES?
AND I WAS SO PRACTITIONER FOR A
NUMBER OF YEARS SO I KNEW WHAT
EXACTLY WHAT IT WAS TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH EVERYTHING THAT YOU
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THAT'S A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER.
AS THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS SAID TO
WHAT MAY BE IMPORTANT TO ONE
SEGMENT OF SMALL BUSINESSES MAY
NOT BE IMPORTANT TO ANOTHER
SEGMENT.
BUT THERE ARE LOTS OF THINGS
THAT -- THAT
ARE COMMON TO ALL OF US AS SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS [INAUDIBLE]
I WE OFTEN HEAR THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN.
THE MOST POWERFUL GENERATOR OF
NEW JOBS HISTORICALLY.
I THINK UP ONE OF THINGS THAT
THAT THE ONE OF THE QUOTES THAT
I HAVE --
HEARD THAT I REALLY LIKE IS THE
FACT THAT START UP COMPANIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL NET JOB
CREATION DURING MOST YEARS.
ALL NET JOB CREATIONS AND THAT'S
ACCORDING TO KAUFFMAN FOUNDATION
IN THEIR REPORT THE IMPORTANCE
OF START UPS.
JOB CREATION AND JOB DESTRUCTION.
SO I'M HERE TO LEARN SO THAT I
CAN BRING THIS INFORMATION BACK
TO MY COMMUNITY THE FORTY
SEVENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT WHICH
IS ENTIRELY.
WITHIN STANFORD TO DO YOU KNOW
COUNTY -- SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU FOR
THE INVITATION NAM LOOKED
LOOKING FORWARD TO AT ALL THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR.
THE THINGS I WILL SAY IT'S
CRITTENDEN NICE TO BE BACK IN
THE GLENDALE CITY COUNCIL
CHAMBERS IT FEELS.
LIKE COMING HOME THIS I WANT TO
THANK THE CITY OF GLENDALE FOR
ALLOWING US TO USE THEIR COUNCIL
CHAMBERS AND FOR BEING GREAT
PARTNERS WITH MY OFFICE FOR THE
PAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
AND WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO OUR SPEAKERS AND AND
NUMBER FINISH WITH OUR SET
SPEAKERS ON THE AGENDA WE WILL
HAVE A BRIEF PRAYER PUBLIC
COMMENTARY. FOR ANYBODY WHO
WANTS TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE --
OUR FIRST SPEAKER --
WHO WILL BE SPEAKING ON THE
TOPIC OF ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL BUSINESSES
JUST A TOURIST THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT [INAUDIBLE]
YOUR TAURUS.
THANK YOU CHAIR THAT YOU ALSO
SIMILAR GO ANDREAS ARE MUCH
APPRECIATE IMITATION AND AND I
JUST WANT SAY THAT --
COOKER WITH MANY OF THE COMMENTS
HE JUST MADE BECAUSE HE OPENING
STATEMENTS AND WHAT I LIKE TO DO
TODAY'S AS THEY PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW A BIT ABOUT THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF THE SECOND
I DEVELOPMENT.
SOME ARE PERMITS RELEASE A SMALL
BUSINESS AND SOME THE ISSUES ARE
SAYING OR SEEN AND HOW WE'RE
LOOKING TO ADDRESS THOSE --
SO LET'S.
I'D SO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS THAT I DEVELOPMENT WE
SERVICES THESE LEAD ENTITY WHEN
IT COMES TO ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
JOB CREATION OF LARGE.
OUT WE HAVE A NUMBER TO VENUS
YOU'LL SEE HERE ON THE SCREEN.
CAN I WOULD SAY THAT I A FEW
THEM A MUCH MORE HIGH PROFILE
THAN OTHERS AND I YOU KNOW I
WON'T GO THROUGH.
EVERY SINGLE UNIT --
PITCHED ONE HIGHLIGHT IF YOU SO
PRICE ON THE MORE I WAS A
PROLIFIC UNITS YOU MAY BE AWARE
OF OUR FOLKS LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
FILM COMMISSION --
WHICH RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DEATH
OF THE FILM.
THE PRODUCTION IS COME BACK TO
CALIFORNIA --
THE CALVARY COMPETE SKINNER
PROGRAM WHICH HAS BEEN RE
AUTHORIZED FOR THEIR FIVE YEARS
THAT MANY.
A MEASURE THAT THE PROGRAM --
OF VISIT CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA CHILD TRAVEL AND
TOURISM BOARD --
AND THEN I WOULD SAY THAT THERE
ARE OTHERS THEIR PRE I CAN OVER
BEHIND [INAUDIBLE]
SMALL.
A LARGE FOR EXAMPLE OUR BUSINESS
IS BUSINESS SERVICES TEAM THERE
AT THE TOP --
WHICH WORKS BEHIND THE SCENES
CONFIDENTIALLY WITH COMPANIES
LIKE AMAZON AND OTHERS AS THEY
DO YOU OF THE SITE LOCATION
SERVICE IS TRYING TO IDENTIFY
INCENTIVES THAT KEEP THEM HERE
CALIFORNIA.
OR I WERE WE COMPETE WITH OTHER
STATES FOR FOR BUSINESSES --
AND ALSO THE FOLKS LIKE THE
PERMANENCE IS THIS UNIT AND ALSO
EVEN MY OWN OFFICE A SMALL
BUSINESSES XENA WHERE WE DO A
LOT OF DIRECT HANDS ON ONE ON
ONE WORD.
NOW WITH BUSINESS OWNERS AND
LARGE THAT THE STATE NOT THINGS
LIKE --
REGULATORY ASSISTANCE.
HOW GENERAL SMALL BUSINESS
ISSUES ETCETERA AND LOOK A LOT
MORE FURTHER INTO THAT?
I'M THIS IS MY OFFICE IS SO
MICHAEL IS POSITIONS WILL BE
DIFFERENT FROM THE OTHER UNITS
AND THAT I SERVICE THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF SMALL BUSINESS
INNOVATION CARGO BAYS BUT ALSO
HOW THE TITLE.
OF PRINCIPLES THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE ECONOMICALLY CITY
CALIFORNIA --
YOU WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL THE
DIFFERENCE THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
THE STATUE LANGUAGE AROUND THE
OFFICE OF SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATE.
NEARLY JULES DOWN TO FOUR CORE
ACTIVITIES SO THERE'S ADVOCACY.
INFORMATION GATHERING
DISSEMINATION AGENCY
COORDINATION AND THE GENERAL
PURPOSES --
ADVOCACY IN THE FORM OF
PROVIDING INFORMATION DATA CAN
BE HELPFUL AS POLICIES ARE BEING
ARRIVE THAT'S OR EVEN --
FOR FOLKS THAT ARE REALLY TO
UNDERSTAND OKAY WHAT IS THIS NEW
REGULATION MEAN TO ME IN MY
BUSINESS WE OFTEN GET ENGAGED IN
THAT KIND OF WORK --
ATTRACTED BY A SECRET NATION
NEXT AGES CORONATION APPARENTLY
AREA ABOUT PROCUREMENT YOU KNOW
I STATE CONTRACTS ARE BEING
ASIDE OUT THERE --
YOU KNOW. FOR ALL THOSE
DIFFERENT STATE AGENCIES OFTEN
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN SMALL
BUSINESS LIAISON THERE IS
ESSENTIALLY A DOT A LINE TO MY
OFFICE IN SO THAT.
IF EVER BUSINESS HAS AN ISSUE
AND SAY --
PUT IN A BID FOR SOME CONTRACT
OR MAYBE THIS NEW SMALL BUSINESS
PROGRAM THAT IS EMERGENCY
CALTRANS FOR OTHER AGENCIES --
THEY CAN CALLS FOR ASSISTANCE IN
TRYING --
GERALD THIS ASSISTANCE --
WHICH IS THE DIRECT ONE ON ONE
FIELD WORK AND THEN THAT SECOND
BULLET THERE INFORMATION
GATHERING DISSEMINATION WHICH I
WOULD CHECK WITH SAME.
IT'S LIKE THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES
THAT WE SEE AND WORK ABOUT THE
DIFFERENCE SMALL BUSINESS
COMMITTEES OF CALIFORNIA.
IS HOW DO YOU GET GREAT
INFORMATION HOW TO SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
CONCERNED THE BREADTH OF OUR
STATE CONSTRAINED THE DIFFERENT
WAYS THAT PEOPLE COMMUNICATE HOW
THE CAN INFORMATION --
SO YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU GET.
THE SOURCE THE COUNTRY BANDS --
HIGH YOU KNOW WHICH SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS USING A WILL WE TRY TO
DO IS IDENTIFY WHO ARE THE
CHAMPIONS OF TO CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT CAN HELP US GET
THE INFORMATION OUT.
ABOUT A REAL THAT'S NOT THIS IS
PROGRAMS OR EVEN JUST THE MEDIA
THE PLATFORMS BY WHICH WE CAN
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM --
TO GET OUT RELEVANT INFORMATION.
AND THAT JUST ON THE RIGHT
YOU'LL SEE THERE ARE A FEW KEY
INITIATIVES --
THAT'LL A TOUCH ON JUST A FEW
THEM AS PART MY PRESENTATION --
BUT WE COVER A PRETTY WIDE GAMUT
UNDERNEATH MY OFFICE --
YOU KNOW MANY OF THOSE ARE NOW
GRANT PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW --
OVERSEE --
SUMMER STATE HAS SOME ARE FAIRLY
FUNDED A BUT ALL ALL DIVE INTO.
SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT MY DECK.
BUT I THOUGHT I START PERSON
JUST ON STATS AND I YOU KNOW
JUST A KEY RESOURCE THAT WE USE
THE U. S. US SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION DOES COME OUT
WHAT THE STATE PROFILE EVERY
YEAR -- THIS
IS THE MOST RECENT INFORMATION --
I CALIFORNIA'S THE MOST SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS IN THIS IN THE
COUNTRY AT THREE POINT NINE
MILLION AT LAST COUNT WE
OUTPACED THE OTHER.
A SEAT LARGER STATES HAVE AT
LEAST A MILLION --
THEY ARE SIGNIFICANT PLAYER HERE
IN THE STATES IN THE EMPLOY
ABOUT SEVEN MILLION WORKERS
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT UNDER 50%.
OF EMPLOYEES AND I WE ALSO DO
YOU RELY QUITE A BIT IN THE
COFFIN FOUNDATION INFORMATION.
IT WILL BE THE LAST --
REPORT THAT CAME OUT AROUND
START UPS INNOVATION AT WHICH I
DO NOT HAVE YOUR THE SCREEN IS
THAT THEY SAID THAT CALIFORNIA'S
AMONGST OF FIVE OTHER STATES
THAT LEAD IN THE AREA OF THE
RECENTLY RETIRED INDIVIDUALS
THEIR SON THE COMING.
THE FIRST TIME AND ALSO ABOUT
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES AND I'M
HAPPY TO GO BACK AND SEE IF THEY
HAVE ISSUED THEIR LATEST RECORD
WHICH MIGHT HAVE.
A DATE FOR MISSION BOYS THINK
THAT'S ONLY PART TO KNOW THAT
RETIREES AND WOMEN OWNED
BUSINESSES ARE.
YOU KNOW SAY IT AS THEY RISE TO
HELP BRING A DEAL LIKE THE RISE
IN ANTI [INAUDIBLE]
STATES I TRIED TO WATCH.
MOLPUS ISSUES THAT WE LOOK TO
ADDRESS -- I
WAS THE FIRST IS AROUND THE IDEA
PERSONALIZED BUSINESS SUPPORT.
AND HOW DO WE SCALE THAT KIND
SUPPORT --
NOW IF YOU KNOW IT IT WOULD SAY
THAT THAT THAT MIGHT BE MY OWN
PERSONAL BIAS HAVING BEEN
FORMALLY A REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR
THE LOS ANGELES SMALL THIS IS AN
ALL STAR NETWORK.
AND ALSO THE STATE'S SHARE ONE
POINT FOR THE STATE PROGRAM.
BUT I WOULD SAY ONE KEY ISSUE
YOU SEE IS THAT YOU HAVE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS LOOKING TO TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS FOR THAT THAT'S A
PERMIT ISSUE AT A LOCAL LEVEL.
I TRY TO ACCESS CAPITAL JUST TO
KNOW HOW TO HOW TO NAVIGATE THAT
WORLD.
OR AYE IT COULD BE ANY ANY KIND
AS IT IS ON A HIGHER FOR THE
FIRST TIME I JUST DON'T HAVE A
SINCE THE HOW TO DO THAT ANYMORE
BECAUSE OF PAN OF WAY.
AND THERE'S THE THERE'S A
TREMENDOUS NEED TO PROVIDE.
THAT INDIVIDUALIZE SHIP.
TRAINING THAT CAN HELP THEM
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE.
AND YOU KNOW I SEE THAT AS FAR
AS A KEY PROGRAMMER KEY FUNCTION
THAT THE STATE COULD USE HOW DO
YOU HELP SUPPORT THAT HE SOLD
SUPPORT THOSE ENTITIES THAT.
CAN HELP BUSINESS OWNERS ADDRESS
CRITICAL ISSUES.
THE OTHER TWO ITEMS THAT HAVE
THAT THERE IS YOU KNOW I ACCESS
TO CAPITAL WHICH HAS ALWAYS BEEN --
AT THE TOP ISSUE YOU KNOW HOW DO
YOU GET THE COUPLE YOU TOUCH GET
YOUR BUSINESS GOING THAT'S BEEN.
YOU KNOW IT IT IN ANY KIND
RICARDO WAS HE ACCESS COUPLE
THERE AT THE TOP PROBABLY SECOND
WOULD BE --
HIRING FOR THE FIRST TIME
FUNDING GOING TO PLEASE BUT
ACCESS COUPLES LEASE BEEN ISSUE.
ASSISTING CALIFORNIA WERE
ESSENTIALLY BECAUSE THE SORT OF
SEE HOW THE BALLOT DEATH NOW YOU
KNOW VERY CHALLENGING FOR FOLKS
TO FIND FUNDING --
UNDER A MILLION DOLLARS TO JUST
I'M GOING OFF IN THE RELY ON A
FRIEND THE FAMILY.
AND THEN I I KNEW ISSUE EMERGING
ISSUE -- TO
ME NOT SO NEW ANYMORE BUT JUST
DOUBLY SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO
RAISE TO YOUR ATTENTION.
BECAUSE WE DON'T FULLY BELIEVE
THAT THIS DESERVES --
IN A STRONG ATTENTION IS
CYBERSECURITY --
AS DESIGNERS NOW --
EXPERIENCE THINGS LIKE AROUND
SOMEWHERE.
POINT IS STILL SYSTEM ISSUES --
GENERAL OF GENERAL TAX FROM ALL
DIFFERENT TYPES IN THE VARIOUS
EACH.
PARTNERS OR ENTITIES AYE THIS IS
BECOMING A A LOOMING ISSUE AND
FRANKLY I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
ENOUGH RESOURCES TO ADDRESS IT
THAT HASN'T BEEN ENOUGH.
ACTIVITY --
TO REALLY ADDRESS THAT I'D A
SMALL BUSINESS LEVEL ONLY IF YOU
LOOK AT THAT PART HOMELESS
SECURITY.
THEY HAVE ESSENTIALLY A DECK OF
HEIDI MEDICAID SEPARATE SCOOTER
RISK.
IT'S EXCITING EIGHTY PAGE
POWERPOINT TEMPLATE THAT
NOBODY'S GONNA READ AND WE NEED
TO FIGURE OUT HOW CAN WE HELP
GET COULD FROM.
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS --
JUST IN THE SAME WAY WE ADDRESS --
EARTHQUAKE PREPAREDNESS DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS AND IT WILL TAKE A
LOOK THEY'LL TALK WITH THEM
ABOUT HOW WE'RE LOOKING SHOULD
JUST AT THE GOBIZ SIDE.
SO LET'S TALK FIRST ABOUT HOWARD
JUST SEEN --
STEALING SMALL BUSINESS SUPPORT
ONE ON ONE SUPPORT --
HER VERY PLEASED TO SHARE THAT
AS PART OF THE THE RECENT PAST
BUDGET WITH THEIR WE HAVE NOW
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THIS YEAR --
TO HELP EXPAND THE CAPACITY OF
THE FEDERAL SMALL BUSINESS
PARTNERS --
SO THIS INCLUDES THE THE SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTERS THE
MINORITY BUSINESS THEIR OWN
SENATORS THE VETERANS THIS.
I RESET HERS TO BECOME A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CENTERS
WOMEN'S BUSINESS CENTERS ALL
THOSE PROGRAMS THAT.
SEE FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
AGENCIES S. B. EIGHT COMMERCE
ETCETERA.
WE ARE ABLE TO NOW PROVIDE THEM
ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO EXPAND THE
CAPACITY YOU JUST ISSUED OUT THE
OUR PIECE OF FOR ALL THESE THE
SPINES AND WE'RE GOING TO BE
RECEIVING THE MAJORITY THOSE
APPLICATIONS BY THE END OF THIS
MONTH.
IT IS BROKEN UP INTO SERIES OF
CHARGES --
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EXPANSION OF CURRENT WORK BEYOND
WHAT THEY'RE REALLY BE SEEN ARE
DOING ATTORNEY THIRD THE FEDERAL
CONTRACTS. THREE MILLION DOLLARS
SPECIFICALLY TO THE SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTERS --
TO SUPPORT THEIR COUPLE --
THE COUPLE WORK AND ANOTHER TWO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EXACTLY.
ALL THE OTHER PROGRAMS BESIDES
SPDC IN THE MANUFACTURING CENTER.
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
MATCH FUNDING TOWARDS THE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS --
YOU KNOW TO GIVE A SENSE.
OF THE SCOPE CURRENTLY.
OF ALL THESE DIFFERENT ELIGIBLE
CENTERS AND THESE ARE THAT THAT
WAS A THAT THE PRINCIPLE OF
FEDERAL BOB PROGRAM SUFFERING
FROM THE STATE.
YOU HAVE SEVENTY TWO CENTERS --
SCATTERED ACROSS THE STATE AT A
DOING GREAT WORK --
OVER HOPING IS THAT THIS MONEY
CAN HELP THEM EXPAND OUR
FOOTPRINT --
TO A MUCH LARGER DECREED THAT
WE'RE SEEING HERE --
SUCH A CALIFORNIA NOR STATES OF
RURAL AREAS AL GORE WERE TRYING
TO DISPLAY HER STAND.
TO ADULT STAFF EXPAND THE
PROGRAMS EXTENDED TRAINING SO
THAT THEY CAN PROVIDE THOSE
CRITICAL ONE ON ONE MENTORSHIPS
ENTRY SUPPORT TO SMALL BUSINESS
ON LOOKS OF THIS IS THAT A
BRANDY PROGRAM GOING OUT.
THE GREAT THING IS THAT THE THE
FUNNY DOES CONTINUE OFTEN NEXT
FOUR YEARS SO I'LL BE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS --
EACH YEAR FOR THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS TO CONTINUE THE PROGRAM --
SO WE'RE EXCITED TO WATCH THAT
AND TO HAVE REPORTERS WORKING
WITH US TO SUPPORT THOSE THIS.
IN ADDITION OUR FILM IS ALSO
DOES DIRECT ONE ON ONE
ASSISTANCE THAT WE PROVIDE
PERMIT --
BERMAN ASSISTANCE THAT DISCOVERS
ANYTHING FROM.
HELPING YOU DRESS UP LOCAL ISSUE
I MEAN FOR EXAMPLE AND MAYBE
YOUR FUME HOOD IS OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WE'VE HAD FOUR
DIFFERENT RESPONSES ABOUT HOW DO
HOW DO YOU DEAL WITH THAT ISSUE
FROM WHAT QUANTITIES.
HOW WE CAN COME AND IT HAS THREE
HOW ONE GROUP WE NEED TO TRUST
THAT -- A
ARE ARE STAFF WHICH IS PART OF
THE BASE IN SACRAMENTO DEALS
WITH A NUMBER DIFFERENT --
ITEMS AND STATE LOCAL FEDERAL
AND BUT WE TRY TO BE JUST THAT
KIND OF KEY SUPPORT SYSTEM TO
BUSINESS SOURCES JUST TO REALLY
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO ABOUT THE
CURRENT ISSUES.
AYE WE ALSO HAVE A TOOL.
COP CAO GOLD. FOR BUSINESS
OWNERS CAN CITY DO A QUICK I
THINK THE TICKET STARTED OR TO
GROW THE CONFLICT BY COUNTY OR
CITY.
OR THEIR BUSINESS TYPING AND SO
SHE GO FROM THERE WOULD ALWAYS
ENCOURAGE A BUSINESS OWNERS IS
TO USE THIS AS A STARTING POINT.
AND THEN IF YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS THEY CAN ALWAYS CALL
US EMBASSY WE DO TO HELP WITH
WHATEVER THEIR PARTICULAR CASES.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE A BUSINESS
PORTAL OR BUSINESS OWNERS CAN
COME IN AND GET --
INFORMATION ON THINGS LIKE --
QUIXTAR BUSINESS GUIDES IF
THEY'RE LOOKING TO START A COMIC
START A BUSINESS LIKE A A
RESTAURANT.
OR CONSULTING FRONT FOR THE
FIRST TIME RECENTLY HAVE A
DOCUMENT THAT LAYS OUT THE STEPS
THAT LEAD TO DO. TO START WITH
BUSINESSES WE HAVE --
SO JANE ANSWERED THAT'S THE
HOUSE --
COLLECTION ALL THE DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS SUBMIT POSTS WAS OVER
THE YEARS AND AND THE NEED
BECAUSE MY SUPPORT THEY CAN
ALWAYS REACH US DIRECTLY THROUGH
THAT PORTAL --
ENCONTRADA SAID IN A IN A PRETTY
ISSUE THIS IS ALSO BEEN A
RESERVOIR OF INFORMATION --
FOR THINGS LIKE DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS OR ANY OTHER THAT I
CAN KIND OF CRITICAL I JUST IN
TIME INFORMATION YOU GET OUT TO
SUSPEND OUR MAIN PLACE TO HEALTH
INFORMATION --
SO WE HOW THESE TOOLS THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE --
DIGITALLY TO TRY TO YOU KNOW
PROVIDE A YOU KNOW.
GENERAL PERMISSION TO BUSINESS
OWNERS AS THEY TRY TO NAVIGATE
THROUGH THEIR THEIR BUSINESS
ITEMS BUT WOULD LIKE I MENTIONED
WE ALSO DID DIRECT ONE OR
SUPPORTS THAT GOBIZ GETS ABOUT
SIX THOUSAND REQUESTS AND ONLY.
A FROM BUSINESS OWNERS AND THOSE
ARE SAMPLING.
OF THE KIND OF QUESTIONS WE GET
AT IT COULD BE ANYTHING FROM --
VETO IT REALLY HAVE BASIC IT IS
FORCE THAT WAS AN EMPLOYEE.
LIKE HOW DO I FIND A MILLION
DOLLARS IN VENTURE FUNDING THESE
ARE ACTUAL QUESTIONS I RECEIVE
THEM LAST LAST YEAR --
BUT WE ALWAYS LIKE TO SAY CSUS
DOT SALAS YOU KNOW AGAIN
LIMITATION BECAUSE IT IS A LOT
ONLY HAS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW FIFTY TO SEVENTY
EMPLOYEES IS THAT I KNOW.
THERE IS A LIMIT STOOD THERE
WERE [INAUDIBLE]
QUESTION SPEAKING [INAUDIBLE]
S. DO DIRECTOR ONE THIS IS THE
WHY WE WOULD PLAN. TO ANOTHER
NURSED. TO FEEL THAT WORK BETTER.
SO THE QUESTIONS WE GET --
AND I JUST WONDER REALLY GUY
QUICKLY HOW LIKE DISASTER
RECOVERY WHICH HAS BEEN --
FAIRLY WAS A FAIRLY NEW TO US --
ADEPTLY SO THEY WILL HAVE TO
LOOK TO DRESS IN A MORE
MEANINGFUL WAY OF MOVING.
THIS DISASTER ASSISTANCE SO OF
MY OFFICE IS OFTEN WHEN THE
FIRST DEPLOYMENT BECAUSE TO BE
RECOVERIES SO WHERE THERE.
IS SNOW MY WORD THEIR SANTA
BARBARA WHEN FIRE SAID WE'RE
ENGAGE WITH THE READING CHEAPER
COMMERCE.
INITIALLY TRIED TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND HOW DID THEY HELP
THEIR BUSINESS OWNERS.
MEDICAID DISASTER AND SOFTEN
RECENTLY IN THE FOR AWHILE FIRE --
THIS IS AN AREA THAT WE'RE
HAVING.
BECAUSE ISSUE WITH THE ABSENCE
OF MERCHANT SERVICES AND OTHERS
ABOUT HOW DO WE HELP BOLSTER.
AT THE RIGHT ONE ONE SYSTEM.
TWENTY DISASTER AND EVEN IN OUR
TWENTY THREE MILLION FRANCE
YOU'LL SEE THAT THOSE SOCIAL
CALL OUT AROUND DISASTER ASSIST.
BECAUSE THAT HASN'T BEEN THERE
BEFORE STATUTE.
AND I JUST IF YOU CAN OTHER AT
ALL UGLINESS OR ENGAGE IN DIRECT
BUSINESSES IT'S WHAT DON'T JUST
LIGHTLY TOUCH UPON.
OUR BUSINESS IT DOESN'T SERVICES
TEAM WISHES I MENTIONED DESKTOP
IT'LL WORK AS OUT COPIES OF THE
CAN DO YOU SITE SELECTION AND
ORDER --
DISCOVERS SENTENCE THAT CAN BE
SO TO THEIR BUSINESS
[INAUDIBLE]
BUT IT BECAUSE OF THE LAW
COMPANIES THAT WORK WITH BUT
THEY ALSO WORK WITH.
THIS TO HELP IDENTIFY.
AWARE SAID ABOUT HOW TO TAP
DISCERN AND AS AND THEN MOVING
ON TO THE IDEA ACCESS TO CAPITAL
ON HOW CAN WE HELP --
DIRECTLY BUSINESSES ADDRESS
THEIR CAPITAL NEEDS I JUST WANT
TO MENTION THAT WE DO YOU HAVE A
UNITS WITH BEEN THAT THE COPAYS
DEPARTMENT --
CALLED THE CALIFORNIA OFFICIALS
TRACK ON THE BILL OF THE BANK
AYE BANK --
THEY ACTUALLY HOW THEIR OWN
SMALL BUSINESS LOAN GUARANTEE
PROGRAM THAT OPERATES THREE
SIMILARLY TO HOW THE U. S. SMALL
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION --
SECURITY SUPPRESSED BUT
TRADITIONAL BLENDERS --
I'D MAKE IT WILL BE DIFFERENT
AND THAT AS THEY WORK THROUGH A
NETWORK OF PARTNERS CALLS
FINANCIAL DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATIONS BUT THROUGH THIS
PARTICULAR SMALL BUSINESS LOAN
GUARANTEE PROGRAM.
THEY'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE CAPITAL
TO BUSINESSES THAT MAY HAVE A
YOU KNOW CHALLENGES PATRICIA
WONDERS SO --
THEY MIGHT BE A START OUT THEY
MIGHT HAVE SOME INTEREST IN THE
CREDIT HISTORY --
SO I MAY HAS A PROGRAM THAT THAT
MAY BE HELPFUL TO THEM AS THEY
LOOK -- TO
YOU KNOW SECURE CAPITAL --
SO THIS IS ONE SPECIFIC PER IF
YOU'RE A COPAYS TO ADDRESS THAT
ACCESS LITTLE ISSUE OF BUT WE
KNOW THAT THIS IS A COMMUNITY
EFFORTS JUST ONE PROGRAM THAT WE
HAVE IN THE MAKES --
BUT WE ALSO RELY ON FOLKS LIKE
OUR PARTNERS AT SBA --
THE AND TRADITIONAL LENDERS TO
HELP ADDRESS ISSUE WHICH IS THE
IS THIS A MUCH EVERY SIGNIFICANT
YOU FOR START UPS AND AND ALSO --
EXISTING BUSINESSES.
AND THEN I AND WANT TO ALSO JUST
HERE YOU KNOW HOW WILL BE THIS
IS A JUST SEEN CYBERSECURITY.
AND IT JUST SO YOU KNOW IT JUST
A QUICK KIND OF COMMENT IS THAT
I IT I RECENTLY TOOK ON THE
INNOVATION --
UNIT WITHIN GO BASED EMERGING
WITH THE SMALL BUSINESS OFFICE
AND IT'S BEEN REMARKABLE TO SEE
HOW MUCH.
OF OUR INNOVATION WORK AS WE ALL
AROUND CYBERSECURITY --
WE HAVE A RATS WITH THE US
DEPARTMENT DEFENSE --
CULT CASCADE PELFREY ABOUT
SUPPLY CHAIN ANALYSIS AND
CREATION UPPER.
THAT EASILY FOR THE FIRST TIME
HELPING US TO MAP OUT --
THE SEX SECURITY LABOR MARKET
AND ALSO JUST THE GENERALS HAVE
MATURITY ISSUES IMPACTING OUR
MANUFACTURERS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES --
ON AUGUST EIGHTH WE ARE GOING TO
BE REALLY SEEN ARE THE RESULTS
OF OUR FIRST FOR MARKET NOW
STUDY.
OF SECU QUICK SENSE OF WHATEVER
PER HAVE.
YEAH I THEIR SAID IN ALARM GAP
BETWEEN.
A NUMBER OF OPEN HIS DANCING
OFFERING.
AT THE END OF THE TALENT THAT
FIT INTO THOSE POSITIONS.
THE REASON WHY THAT NEEDS TO BE
IS A CONCERN TO US WHO ARE
INTERESTED IN SUPPORT OF SMALL
BUSINESSES IS THAT.
WAY AND AN ATTACK HAPPENS TO
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER.
OFTEN THEY DON'T HOW THE PERSON
THEY NEED TO ADDRESS THAT YOU
KNOW BILLS GO TO THEIR C. O.
ORDERED THEIR IT --
GUY SAY HOW ONE IS SAFE.
FIX THIS PROBLEM AND UP UNTIL
BEADS THE GAP OF THE SKILLS THE
SEARCH ADDRESS THAT ISSUE SO
WORDS I UNDERSTAND IS TO SPREAD.
AND TAKE A DOD.
IS ONE OF THE SKILLS THAT ARE
NECESSARY [INAUDIBLE]
TO SKILL --
TO ADDRESSES ISSUES YOU KNOW
WHAT KIND OF PERSON WE NEED A
HIGHER WOULD YOU FIND THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
OF WHATEVER COMMITTEE SQUEE
PROVIDE A SOURCE TRAINING
PROGRAMS ARE CREEK LAND THEY CAN
HELP TRAIN --
INDIVIDUAL SUBSIDIES TO BE PART
OF A SMALL BUT SIXTEEN TO
ADDRESS THESE.
WE MEET AND ISSUE --
OF THIS A LOT OF PERMISSION CAN
PROVIDE AROUND SERVICE COULD A
LARGE SHOULD BE WORKING JOSH
WOULD DEPARTMENT SECURITY IN THE
PARK DEFENSE --
THIS ISSUE --
BUT THIS IS ONE OF MY CORE
MISSION OF UNDERNEATH MY OFFICE
THAT WE LOOK. TO TO ADDRESS ON
THE SERVER SCREEN THIS IS --
IN ADDITION WE DO OVERSEE THE
CALPERS CYBER INNOVATION
CHALLENGE THIS IS STUDENT
COMPETITION.
I AM PARTIAL TO CALIFORNIA --
AT UNIVERSITY OF POLITICALLY
RISKY THE SALAS OBISPO --
REALLY WHAT THIS IS ESSENTIALLY
A TWENTY EIGHTEEN COMPETITION OF
STUDENTS FROM HIGH SCHOOLS
AROUND CALIFORNIA --
WHERE THEY DO A FORENSICS AND
AND OUR CHALLENGE AND --
REALLY THE A ALL THOSE WHO
DISAGREE FUND COMPETITION THE
OVERALL TEN HISTORY HIGHLIGHTS
THE IMPORTANCE OF RECURSION
STUDENTS TO HAUNT CAREERS IN THE
SPACE -- WE
HELD A WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
SUMMIT FOR OUR COMPETITION THIS
YEAR FOR THE FIRST TIME --
WE HAD AS A MEMBER JACQUI IRWIN
PARTICIPATE AS I CHOSE THE
COMMITTEE ON SECURITY AND REALLY
WERE TIED TO JUST TRY HIGHLIGHTS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF GOING UP
PATHWAYS TO CYBERSECURITY --
TO OR TO REALLY REINFORCE THAT
TALENT PIPELINE FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
AND THEN JUST THAT THE LAST THE
INITIAL ONE MISSION ON
CYBERSECURITY.
IS OUR REALTY NEW PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE UC CENTER FOR BY TO
KEEP YOU NEED --
THIS IS THAT I TO HELP ADVISORY
BOARD THAT WE CREATING A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM --
YEAH.
THE I. T. HEALTH HISTORY THE AS
A WHOLE AT ITS EXPERT THINGS OF
INTERESTING CHALLENGES.
AROUND IT TO CURE <C.GREEN> --</C>
A NO AS THEY COLLECT OF BIOLOGY
INFORMATION BUT FOR PEACE DANCE
AT THE PIANO BY EAR PICKUP
TWENTY THREE ME IN YOUR OR EVEN.
A TEASING [INAUDIBLE]
TRACKING IS.
THE RATES OF NFL PLAYERS THEIR
BODY OF DATA TO MAKE BY.
ALL THESE DIFFERENT FIRMS THAT I
AND THE CONCERN ABOUT.
BEING ATTACKED STOLEN SOMETHING
AWAY SO OVER TO DEAL WITH THEM
IS BECOMING OF A RECOMMENDATION.
THE HIGH TECH THIS INFORMATION
AND WHAT YOU NEED OUT AS A THREE
TIERED PROCESS IT IS OUT WE
THINK THIS IS THE START OF AND
THE CREATION.
OF ADDITIONAL INDUSTRY GROUPS
LATER I CYBERSECURITY.
BUT THIS IS JUST THE FIRST OF
ITS LEE EMERGED WHERE YOU SEE.
DIRECTLY APPROACH DISPERSE POR.
THE OTHER THING
[INAUDIBLE]
GOLD IS [INAUDIBLE]
IT'LL
.
REALLY FOR THE FIRST TIME --
OR RELEASE IN THE AND IT REALLY
EXTENSIVE KIND OF WAY --
SOBRE HOPING THAT WE CAN USE
THAT AS A WAY TO ENCOURAGE OUR
PARTNERS TO DEVELOP OUR SMALL
BUSINESS RELEVANT --
CYBERSECURITY PLANS AND AND
MITIGATION EFFORTS --
WITH THAT HAVE THE QUESTIONS
[INAUDIBLE]
THROUGH THIS.
THANK YOU FIRST TRY TO TAKE
NOTES ZERO SPEAKING THERE ARE SO
MANY THINGS IN SOME.
IT SANDRA DAY NOTICE AREA THAT I
REPRESENT.
BUT THERE IS GREAT NEED --
YOU TALKED ABOUT SMALL BUSINESS
ISSUES AND THE GOBIZ APPROACH.
AND ONE WAS ACCESS TO CAPITAL
AND YOU SAW WAS.
NODDING THAT'S ONE OF THE AREAS
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES REALLY
NEED HELP THERE [INAUDIBLE]
EIGHT WOULD THE OPPORTUNITY
ZONES IS A SOMETHING YOU'RE
GOING TO INTERFACE WITH THAT ARE
YOU GOING TO BE PROVIDING OF
REGARDING THAT YES IN FACT
ASSIST YESTERDAY THOSE --
IMMEDIATE HELP BY SOME MEMBER
QUIRK SILVA.
IN ORANGE COUNTY --
AROUND THAT AND I THINK I
GRAYSON I IMAGINE THAT THAT
GROUP AROUND CANNABIS OF THE
STILL WANT TO BE DETERMINED THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
ABOUT -- HOW
DEALERS THE PROGRAM AND YOU KNOW
IT'S A SERIOUS STILL VERY EARLY
STAGE WILL BE INTERESTING TO SEE?
HOW COMMUNITY COMMITTEES CAN USE
THAT PROGRAM TO SAVE?
MAYBE NOT BRING IN LARGER
CORPORATIONS TO DO SO PENSION
LIKE FOR EXAMPLE THAT IT WAS
BROUGHT UP WITH THE IDEA OF
COULD YOU CREATE A SMALL
BUSINESS VILLAGE IN THE IN THE
COMMUNITY.
IS DOES THAT --
THAT THAT PER TO CREATE A A AND
YOU AYE CITY THAT WERE.
THEY CAN BE SET UP FOR THAT THEY
CAN HIRE WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
AND AND ALSO PROVIDE EARLY
CONVERSELY RESOURCES AND A
RESOURCE TO THE COMMUNITY.
A BUT I WOULD SAY A RELEASE
RIGHT NOW WHERE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STILL TRYING TO IT.
REALLY HAD HAMMERED ON THE
REGULATIONS WILL BE EARLY TO SEE --
IS THIS GOING TO BE A GAME
CHANGER ARE JUST ANOTHER TOOL IN
THE TOOLBOX FOR COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU --
WITH THE CAL GOLD.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE PERMITTING
PROCESS IT'S VERY INTERESTING.
IT'S ONE OF THE BIGGEST
[INAUDIBLE]
THIS WAS IS THAT.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE TO GO WHEN
YOU START ONE DEPARTMENT AND
THEN THEY SENT TO ANOTHER AND
IT'S LIKE THEY DON'T WANT TO
BUSINESS.
WE WANT TO BE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY KNOWS WE WANT TO
BUSINESS AND WE WANT TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WOULD MAKE IT BUSINESS
FRIENDLY.
DO YOU WORK WITH THE CITY'S
THEMSELVES TO HELP THEM
STREAMLINED THEIR PERMITTING
PROCESS ALL.
S. E. NO I WOULD SAY THAT.
THE YOU KNOW WHAT WE DO IS WE
LOOK TO PARTNER WITH THEM AND TO
HELP.
KIND AND YOU KNOW TO REMOVE
REMOVE THE CONFUSIONS PERSONAL
BUSINESS SO WE WENT AND NESTLE
GOING TO CEDAR KIND OF SAFE.
THIS IS HOW YOU SHOULD DO A BILL
SAYS THAT.
WE'VE HAD OF THE CENTER APPROACH
US WITH THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO HELP YOU
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IF THERE IS --
AT DOCUMENT WE HELPED CREATE CAN
WE HAVE A MEETING --
TO HELP CREATE A NEEDS ARE
POWERFULLY FOR THIS BUSINESS
OWNER SOCIALLY THE LOOKING TO
CREATE JOBS --
SUCH AS WILL BE SEEN AS THAT
THEIR SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW AS AS INDIVIDUALS
CHANGE POSITIONS WITHIN CITY
GOVERNMENT UMPTEEN OTHER MIGHT
BE RECALL ONE INDIVIDUAL
INNOCENTLY ANOTHER PERSON IT'S
AND IT MAY NOT HAVE THE CASE
ESSENTIALLY.
SO WE BELIEVE SOME OF WHICH I DO
IS WHINE.
HELP THEM ADJUST WHATEVER THAT
PARTICULAR BUSINESS CONCERN IS
THAT ALSO PROVIDE --
YOU KNOW BEST PRACTICES AS WE
ARE ABLE TO TRAVEL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE TO SAY.
PAGE YOU KNOW IT'S YOU BE MOVE
FOR A YOUR CANNABIS POLICY.
HAVE A PARTIAL WAS HOLLYWOOD
BECAUSE THAT A VERY INTRIGUING
PROCESS WHEN IT COMES TO YOU --
IDENTIFY THE SOCIAL BENEFIT TO
THE COMMUNITY SO WE TRIED TO
THAT SPECIFIC CAN --
YOU KNOW WE DID AS A SESSION
DOWN IMPERIAL --
AROUND CUT ISSUED INDUSTRY I
SAID YOU ARE.
I ANY SET OF STANDARDS FOR THEIR
THEIR AREA THAT WERE PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION THAT WE TOOK
BACK TO OTHER PLACES AND SO
CALIFORNIA TO SHOW THEIR FACES
SO WE TRIED TO THAT AS WELL
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
HOW MANY CALLS DO YOU GET FROM
SAMBA DE NO INLAND EMPIRE AREA?
TO MY PEOPLE USELESS.
THEY USE IT AND I'LL LCP CAN
PULL THAT INFORMATION FUSELI
WOMAN AS FAR AS THE MADE LAST
YEAR -- BUT
WE GET THEM WE GET THE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE'S.
I TRY TO THINK OF I'M ANYTHING
RECENTLY COME THROUGH.
BUT WHAT A SUMMIT YOU KNOW --
THAT'S MY PERSONAL CELL PHONE
NUMBER.
YOU CAN ALWAYS GIVE THAT OUT TO
ANY BUSINESS OWNER YOU'RE
WORKING WITH THAN HAPPY TO MAKE
IT WILL JUST GO.
I WAS LIKE ONE SEE WHAT IT IS I
WANT TO SEE IF MY COMMUNITY IS
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF IT.
AGAIN IF THEY'RE NOT WHAT IT IS
WE NEED TO DO IN THE ASSEMBLY
OFFICE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
TAKE ADVANTAGE.
I DON'T.
THINK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU THAT WAS --
PRESENTATION I'M SURE WILL BE OF
INTEREST TO A LOT OF BUSINESSES
AND I HOPE THAT YOU CAN STATE
THROUGH THE AND A CASE OF THESE
QUESTIONS COME UP.
WE HEAR THE NEXT PANELIST.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VISITORS
NEXT WE'LL BE HEARING FROM
PATRICK NEITHER REGIONAL
DIRECTOR FROM THE LOS ANGELES
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT.
WELCOME STERN I THANKS FOR
JOINING US A GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING --
SO YEAH MY NAME IS PAT NINE A
AND I REPRESENT THE LOS ANGELES
REGIONAL SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER NETWORK --
WHERE ONE OF FIVE NETWORK ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OF THAT
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESS --
OUR TERRITORY COVERS A LOS
ANGELES VENTURA AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTIES.
THE WHOLE PROGRAM IS IS BROUGHT
TO OUR REGION BY LONG BEACH CITY
COLLEGE.
AND WERE PART OF THAT A BROADER
SERIES OF PROGRAMS THAT --
REALLY FOCUS ON WORKFORCE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THROUGHOUT
OUR REGION.
YOU'LL HEAR A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT SOME OF OUR OTHER PROGRAMS
FURTHER ON IN THE THREE TATIAN --
SO WE ARE ACTUALLY ONE OF THE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PARTNERS
THAT --
MISTER TAURUS SPOKE ABOUT --
VS BDCS BEING ONE OF THE LARGEST
SORT OF ONE OF ONE ADVISING
REESE.
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE --
ACROSS CALIFORNIA THERE
APPROXIMATELY FORTY FIVE SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTER.
ACTUAL CENTERS --
IN OUR REGION --
WE COVER ABOUT.
WE HAVE EIGHT SENATORS AND ABOUT
A HUNDRED FIFTEEN ADVISORS THAT
WORK -- OUR
PRIMARY ACTIVITIES OUR TRAININGS
WORKSHOPS AND THEN THE ONE ON
ONE ADVISING IT'S REALLY OUR
CORE ACTIVITY --
JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE WE DO
EVERYTHING FROM HELPING A
BUSINESS THEIR BUSINESS PLAN.
WE HELP THEM WITH MARKETING
CONCERNS --
DISASTER RECOVERY SO WE DID
QUITE A BIT OF WORK.
AROUND THE TIME SUPPLIERS
EARLIER THIS YEAR.
I'M HELPING BUSINESSES NAVIGATE
OUR BRIDGE LANDING --
GETTING THEIR INSURANCE IN ORDER
EVERYTHING YOU KNOW TO GET BACK
UP ON THE WILSON DO QUITE A BIT.
INTERNATIONAL TRADE AS WELL AS
KNOWLEDGE A REALLY TOUCHING ALL
SECTORS OF SMALL BUSINESS.
AND I SHOULD NOTE THAT OUR
DEFINITION OF SMALL BUSINESS
ACTUALLY FAIRLY LARGE --
TENDS TO BE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES [INAUDIBLE]
ROUGHLY ABOUT. SEVEN AND A HALF
MILLION IN REVENUE.
SO SOME PRETTY BIG PLAYERS UP
THERE ALL THE WAY DOWN TO YOUR
LOCAL MOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
REGION LAST YEAR WE HELPED --
ABOUT FORTY TWO HUNDRED CLIENTS --
WE CREATED OUR HELP THEM TO
CREATES JUST UNDER FIFTY HUNDRED
JOBS --
THIRTY THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
A NEW BUSINESSES STARTED.
AND WE HELP THEM SECURE CAPITAL --
TOTALING JUST UNDER HUNTER FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
SO THOSE ARE SORT OF THE CORE
GOALS ACTUAL SOME MENTION WERE
BOTH FUNDED --
BY A GRANT FROM THE SMALL
BUSINESS ADMINISTRATION AS WELL
AS IS IS JUST YOU MENTIONED --
SOME STATE FUNDING AND WE'RE
VERY EXCITED TO SEE THAT
OPPORTUNE CHRIS THIS YEAR.
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO DO
QUITE A BIT MORE OF WHAT THE
BEGIN --
THAT AND I APOLOGIZE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AS I DON'T HAVE DATA FOR
YOUR AREA --
BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER FREEMAN
ABOUT WELFARE.
WE CAN MAKE SURE TO GET IT ALL
IN MY COUNTERPART FROM COUNTY
FALL.
THANK YOU SOUNDS.
SO WITHIN THE FORTY THIRD
DISTRICT --
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS WE
PROVIDED JUST UNDER THREE
THOUSAND COUNSELING HOURS
INDIVIDUAL HOURS TO A SMALL
BUSINESSES WITHIN THE REGION.
OVER TWO HUNDRED FIFTY CLIENTS
SO WE'VE BEEN PRETTY ACTIVE --
WE'VE HAD.
ABOUT THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED SO
TRAINING ATTENDEES FOR DIFFERENT
WORKSHOPS WE GIVE. TO PROVIDE OF
FREE OR LOW COST EXPERTISE TO
OUR BUSINESS OWNERS --
WE'VE HELPED START TWENTY FOUR
NEW BUSINESSES AND SECURED OVER
SEVENTEEN MILLION.
SO JUST WITHIN THEIR REGION.
FAIRLY ACTIVE AGAIN WITH THAT
INCREASE FUNDING WE LOOK TO IT
REALLY RAPTOR EFFORTS UP ACROSS
OUR WHOLE AREA --
MOST CLIENTS COME TO US LOOKING
FOR ONE OF THREE TOP THINGS --
CAPITAL THAT'S ALWAYS IMPORTANT
FOR EITHER GETTING STARTED OR
GROSS OR EVEN DEALING WITH --
SORT OF EMERGENCIES --
BUSINESS PLANS EVEN IF IT'S JUST
A VERY BASIC ONE BUSINESSES
OFTEN --
SORT OF GET AHEAD OF THEMSELVES
AND THEN FIND OUT ARE WE
ACTUALLY.
PAPER SO WE HELP US FOCUS
NAVIGATE [INAUDIBLE]
THROUGH.
NAVIGATING DOT THEIR PLANS AND
THEN OF MARKETING.
THAT'S EVERYTHING FROM MY NEED A
WEBSITE TO HELP ME FIGURE OUT
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCESS YOU
COMPETITORS POSTING ALL THE TIME.
WE KNOW WE NEED TO BE THERE TOO
AND SO WE DO QUITE A BIT ON
BUILDING STRATEGIES AROUND US
THAT.
RATHER THAN JUST --
PURGING BUSINESSES TO DO ONE OFF
ACTIVITIES WE LIKE TO HELP THEM
SLOW DOWN A LITTLE BIT TAKE A
MORE HOLISTIC APPROACH THEIR
BUSINESS.
AND REALLY PLAY STRATEGY --
IN TERMS OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
WE SEE MOST OF OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES OF FACING --
ONE OF THE BIGGEST IS ACCESS TO
CAPITAL AND SO THAT'S ONE OF OUR
MAJOR GOALS --
ASSOCIATED WITH.
YES BE A GRAMM WE RECEIVED ON
THE FEDERAL SIDE AS WELL AS ONE
OF THE MAJOR ACTIVITY.
CORD WITH THE GLOBUS GRANDSON ON
THE STATE SIDE.
AND THAT'S OFTENTIMES IS HELPING
BUSINESSES NAVIGATE --
WHAT MIGHT BE THE BETTER BEST
OPPORTUNITY FOR FUNDING HOW TO
GET THEIR FINANCES IN ORDER HOW
TO ACTUALLY PACKAGE --
THEIR THEIR DOCUMENTS IN.
WE ONLY GO SHOP ALONE --
IN OUR NETWORK WE'VE ACTUALLY
DEVELOPED A WHOLE TEAM THAT JUST
DOES THIS IT'S CALLED THE ACCESS
TO CAPITAL TEAM.
IN THEIR OWN CALLS BASICALLY
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN TO WORK WITH A
SMALL BUSINESS THAT MIGHT NEED
TO NAVIGATE FUNDING --
AND YOU NEED CONTACTS WITH BANKS
MIGHT NEED TO GET THEIR FINANCES
IN ORDER MAY NEED TO IMPROVE
THEIR CREDIT SCORES WE CAN HELP
NAVIGATE ALL OF THAT.
AND WE HAVE THE LUCKY POSITION
OF BEING AGNOSTIC ON THE LANDING
OPPORTUNITY MIGHT BE THROUGH.
WE'VE WE'VE REALLY THERE ON THE
SIDE OF THE CLIENTS. TO GIVE
THEM THE BEST DEAL POSSIBLE TO
MOVE THEIR BUSINESS FORWARD.
GROWING HOPEFULLY AT JOBS IN.
DEVELOPMENT TO OUR COMMUNITY --
OF FINANCIAL LITERACY WE FIND IS
ALSO A BIG STRUGGLE SO A NUMBER
OF OUR TRAININGS AND ADVISING
FOLKS ON THIS --
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF CLIENTS WHO
COME TO US --
AND THEY'RE NOT EVEN SURE IF
THEY'RE PROFITABLE.
SO THEY'RE SO BUSY RUNNING THE
DAY TO DAY BUSINESS THAT THE
TIME TO REALLY DIG IN AND LEARN
EVERYTHING [INAUDIBLE] TO WE'RE
ALL THOSE HATS THAT A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER NEEDS TO WEAR SO
WE REALLY HOPE HE'S THAT APART
AND DISTILL IT DOWN TO AN
APPROACH THAT.
REALLY GIVES A SMALL BUSINESS IN
UNDERSTANDING HOW THEY'RE DOING
AND WHERE THEY CAN MAKE
IMPROVEMENTS IN.
SHE GOT EFFICIENCY --
WE'LL SO I ENCOUNTER.
A LOT OF BUSINESSES WHO ARE
TRYING TO NAVIGATE ARE
PERMITTING PROCESS.
YOU MENTIONED --
THE THE CITY YOU KNOW HAS A
DIFFERENT PROCESS AND CAN BE
VERY CHALLENGING WE FIND THAT A
LOT OF THE CITIES WE SERVE
WITHIN OUR REGION.
THAT'S APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY AIDS
JUST AND ONLY ALLOW --
THEY'LL HAVE --
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT PROCESS SEES
THEY MIGHT BE UNDERSTAFFED THEY
MIGHT NOT HAVE ALL THE RESOURCES.
SO WE'VE BEEN ENGAGING DESERVE
CITIES DIRECTLY. TO HELP LEARN
THEIR PROCESS SEIZE AND THEN BE
ABLE TO CONVEY THAT TO THE
CLIENTS THAT WE MIGHT REPRESENT
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
SO WE'RE NOT IN A POSITION TO
TELL THE CITY HOW TO DO IT BUT
WE CAN CERTAINLY LEARNED.
THEY APPROACH IT SHARE BEST
PRACTICES AND THEN MAKE SURE
THAT THAT INFORMATION GETS DOWN
TO THE BUSINESS --
WE CAN EVEN HELP HAND HOLD THAT
BUSINESS THROUGH THE PROCESS.
SO WERE WERE THINK THINKING OF
OUR CLIENTS BEYOND JUST THE
SMALL BUSINESS ITSELF.
AND ACTUALLY ENGAGING CITIES AND
COMMUNITIES IN OUR AREA TO SORT
OF BE THAT GO BETWEEN HELP OF
THIS IS NOW TO GET ALL THAT --
WE'RE ALSO SEEING A LOT OF
PRESSURE ON A RETAILER SERVE OUR
BRICK AND MORTAR.
MANY SENSE IS A PERFECT STORM --
WE'RE SEEING ARE RAPIDLY
INCREASING OF RENTS.
IN OUR REGION ALONG WITH.
HOUSING AND ALL THAT THERE'S
JUST A LOT OF PRESSURE ON SPACE --
WERE SEEING RISING EMPLOYEE
BECAUSE THINGS LIKE --
THE MINIMUM MINIMUM WAGE
REQUIREMENTS AND EVERYTHING.
WHILE THAT MAY BE A GREAT THING
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL THAT BECOMES
A REAL CHALLENGE FOR THAT SMALL
BUSINESS. ONE THEY MAY NOT HAVE
ANTICIPATED ARE NOW HAVING TO
REACT -- TO
GROSSES SEEM QUITE A BIT OF
COMPETITION.
IN THE ONLINE SPACE.
SO ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE
REALLY IMPACTING OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO YOU KNOW
HAVE THOSE EXPERTS ON HAND.
OUR VISORS.
WE HAVE AGE OUR EXPERTISE
SURVEYING.
STAND YOU COMMERCE AND HELP
THOSE BUSINESSES INVOLVED IN
MAYBE THINK ABOUT THEMSELVES A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY THAN THEY
MAY HAVE TRADITIONALLY.
IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH THESE NEW
CHALLENGES THEY MAY NOT A FACED
OVER THERE HAS --
AS I MENTIONED WE WE DEAL WITH
QUITE A BIT OF MARKETING ISSUE
SO THIS IS ONE AREA THAT --
YOUR TYPICAL SMALL BUSINESS.
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO AFFORD AN
OUTSIDE AGENCY OR THE LUXURY OF
HAVING A MARKETING DEPARTMENT
TERMINALLY.
SO WE PROVIDES --
SEVERAL DIFFERENT TYPES OF
EXPERTS THROUGHOUT OUR NETWORK
TO WORK WITH THIS.
WHAT I WANT --
AND WE MAY EVEN TO PLAY WHOLE
TEAM TO A BUSINESS SO THAT THEY
GET EXPERT.
WEBSITE IF YOU COMMERCE.
BRANDING IN ALL THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS AND REALLY.
ARE TRYING TO MAKE THOSE SMALL
WHOSE [INAUDIBLE]
EXPERTS WHEN THEY ARE GOING OUT
TO MARKET AND MAYBE WHEN THEY DO
WORK WITH THE VENDOR.
THEY KNOW THE QUESTIONS TO ASK.
SO THEY CAN.
FEEL COMFORTABLE HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS --
HR AND HEALTH CARE HAS BECOME A
BIG ISSUE AND YOUR REGULATIONS
TO SEEMS SHIFT PRETTY RAPIDLY
AND THAT'S A LOT FOR A SMALL
BUSINESS KEEP UP WITH.
SO WE OFFERED A NUMBER OF
WORKSHOPS THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
JUST THROUGH.
PEOPLE ABREAST OF THE CHANGES WE
ALSO OFFER ONE ONE ADVISING.
TO ANYBODY WHO'S RUNNING INTO
ISSUES AND JUST EVEN THROUGH OUR
OR COMMUNICATIONS THESE LETTERS
AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
WERE MAKING SURE TO POPULATE
THAT WITH UPCOMING ISSUES.
SO THIS SHOULD BE PAYING
ATTENTION SO WE STILL.
TRIES TO REMAIN TOP OF MIND --
THEN THE AS IS MR TOWARDS
POINTED OUT.
CYBERSECURITY WE THINK IS IS
ALSO A PRETTY BIG THREAT TO
SMALL BUSINESS.
WE FIELDED SOME CALLS HERE AND
THERE WITH --
COME FACING ATTACKS ON THEIR
WEBSITE --
BUT WE DON'T THINK THERE'S BEEN
A REALLY GREAT SORT OF HOLISTIC
APPROACH TO SO.
PART OF OUR PROPOSAL I'M TO SOME
OF THAT STATE FUNDING AND YOU'RE
WITH THIS YEAR'S FEDERAL GRANT.
WE'RE GONNA BE FOCUSING MORE ON
EVER CYBERSECURITY OFFERINGS
DOING WORKSHOPS PARTNERING WITH
OTHER AGENCIES THAT MAY HAVE
SOME DEATH IN THIS.
AND THEN BRING TO OUR SMALL.
SO THAT'S JUST A HANDFUL OF THE
CHALLENGES [INAUDIBLE]
OUR SMALL.
THAT ARE.
OPEN FOR QUESTIONS [INAUDIBLE]
SOME MEMBERS.
THANK YOU --
YOU THE ONE OF THE LESSONS YOU
TALKED ABOUT REGARDING MARKETING.
YOU SAID YOU'RE DEPLOYED EXPERTS
AS A TEAM TO GO TO THE BUSINESS.
FREE SERVICE YES --
CITY SBDC SERVICES ARE FREE TO
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS --
IMPORTANT WERE NOT ACTUALLY
EFFORTS IT'S WE WOULDN'T BUILD
THEIR WEBSITE FOR THEM BUT WE
TEACH THEM WHAT THEY NEED TO ASK
FOR HOW TO MAKE THAT COMPLEMENT.
YOU KNOW THE REST OF THEIR
MARKETING STRATEGIES THAT WILL
WORK ON WITH [INAUDIBLE]
AND WELL WORST NETWORK CERTAINLY
HAS SOME GENERALIST THAT CAN
WORK WITH ANY BUSINESS.
WE FUNDED SOCIAL VALUE BUT HAVE
PEOPLE WITH SPECIFIC INDUSTRY.
OR SKILL EXPERTISE SO SMALL
BUSINESS MAY HAVE A GENERAL US
WORKING WITH THEM ON A NUMBER OF
THINGS.
THEN WHEN IT COMES TIME FOR
THEIR MARKETING WE MAY PULL EN.
ECOMMERCE EXPERT AT WEB EXPERT
YOU KNOW SORT OF A TEAM WE CAN
DRAW FROM THROUGHOUT OUR NETWORK.
ROUGHLY HONOR FIFTEEN VISORS.
TO HELP YOU KNOW BASICALLY GIVE
THE BEST ADVICE TO THAT BUSINESS
PROVIDE.
IT YOU'RE THAT YOU'RE THE LOS
ANGELES SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTER I WOULD
ASSUME PACKED IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE THINK IT'S RIVERSIDE THAT
HOUSE.
ONE PARENT SAID THAT WOULD BE
THROUGH ORANGE COUNTY INLAND
EMPIRE --
AND SO I HAVE A COUNTERPART MY
DANIEL WHO.
RUNS THAT REGION THERE'S ANOTHER
ONE THAT'S AND DIEGO AREA.
AND THEN THE CENTRAL COAST AND
THEN NORTH.
SO WERE BROKEN INTO REGIONS
SPEZZA.
WE WORK COLLABORATIVELY WE MEET
MONTHLY.
TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN.
YEAH BOTH LEARN FROM ONE ANOTHER
BUT ALSO BRING THESE SERVICES
ACROSS THE STATE ESPECIALLY WHEN
WE FACED THINGS LIKE --
STATEWIDE NATURAL DISASTERS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. FOR THOSE WHO
ARE WATCHING --
WHERE WOULD THEY?
WOULD SPEAK THAT WEBSITE TO THE
THAT THEY WOULD GO TO TO HAVE
ACCESS. TO FIND OUT THE CLOSEST --
SMALL BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
CENTER -- IT
SAYS SMALL BIZ LA DOT ORG.
WOULD BE THE BEST PLACE TO GET
STARTED.
AND THE LAST QUESTION IS THIS
ACCESS TO CAPITAL TEAM.
IF SOMEBODY COMES IN AND THAT'S
THE BIGGEST ISSUE IS TO HAVE
ACCESS CAPITAL THEN YOU PUT THE
TEAM ON TO HELP THEM.
FIGURE OUT TO NAVIGATE --
TO YEAH SO I THINK IT WILL --
WILL YOU ASK FOR THEIR
FINANCIALS AND HELP GET THOSE IN
ORDER --
WILL DEVELOP A SHORT BUSINESS
PLAN FOR THEM WILL WILL
ESSENTIALLY PACKAGE EVERYTHING
TOGETHER.
WITH AN EYE TOWARDS WHAT THE
LENDERS.
SOMETHING THAT A BUSINESS MIGHT
HAVE A LOT OF EXPERIENCE AND
THAT WE DO AND WE WORK WITH
THESE LETTERS ALL THE TIME AND
HAVE A REALLY GOOD PULSE ON WHAT
THEY NEED IN ORDER.
TO ACTUALLY CONSIDER SMALL
BUSINESS APPLICATION --
SO WE BASICALLY PUT THEM FORWARD
ON THE BEST FOOTING POSSIBLE.
DID I KNOW THAT THERE'S LOTS
THAT'S DOWN TOWARD THE BIGGER
SMALL BUSINESSES.
IS THERE IS THERE SOMEBODY WHO
IS IN YOUR DEPARTMENT THAT IS
MORE CONCERNED ABOUT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THOSE WHO HAVE LESS
THAN FIFTY EMPLOYEES.
THOSE WITH THE WITH.
SMALLER BUSINESSES WE CONSIDER
THEM ALL OUR CLIENTS SO WE HAVE
NOT SEGREGATED THAT WAY I WILL
SEGREGATE ACCORDING.
TO INDUSTRIES SO IF IT'S A
RETAILER WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE AN EXPERT IN THAT AREA.
THIS IS A MAN FACTURE --
BUT I'D SAY MOST OF OUR
CLIENTELE COMES FROM.
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING TO IN TERMS
OF?
SMALLER AND OF THAT SPECTRUM A
SMALL DOES.
WE WORKED WITH A LOT OF
RESTAURANTS A MOM AND POP
RETAILERS --
YEAH WE'RE SO FOCUSED ON
STARTUPS SO THAT MIGHT BE A
REALLY SMALL TEAM TO BEGIN WITH
THAT'S LOOKING TO GROW.
AND WE HOPE TO STAY WITH THEM
OVER YOU KNOW THEIR EVOLUTION
INTO.
THE BIGGER AND THAT'S WHAT IS
THEIR COMMITMENT TO YOU. FOR YOU
TO PROVIDE SERVICE TO THEM WHAT
IS THEIR COMMITMENT THE THEY
SUCH WE NEED TO FILL OUT A
LITTLE BIT OF PAPERWORK --
ALTHOUGH SHOULD MENTION PEOPLE
THAT CONFIDENTIAL WELL WE ARE
FEDERALLY FUNDED SO I'M NOT OF
THAT IS SHARED BEYOND OUR OUR
CENTER WE HAVE.
PERRY TERROR DATABASE WE PROVIDE
ANY INFORMATION OUTSIDE OF
ORGANIZATION [INAUDIBLE]
IN AGGREGATE --
SO YOU MIGHT BILL TO GET DATA
MEMBERS WOULD YOU WANT NOTABLY
THE BUSINESSES BEHIND THAT
UNLESS THEY'VE ELECTED.
TO BECOME A SUCCESS STORY OR
LOUDEST BRAG ABOUT THEM.
THAT SAID THEY JUST NEED TO MEET
WITH US AND THEN I RECEIVED
ONGOING THEY NEED. TO ACTUALLY.
DOING THE WORK TO GROW THEIR
BUSINESS.
WE CAN DO FOR THEM BUT WE CAN
CERTAINLY EMPOWER THEM --
TO ADDRESS WHATEVER ISSUES THEY
MIGHT BE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU HUNTER.
THANK YOU COMMA I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT NOT
HAVE ANSWERS FOR BUT THERE ARE
THINGS THAT ARE --
TOPICAL HERE IN THE AREA.
THE FIRST ONE HAS TO DO WITH.
THE PRICE OF COMMERCIAL RENTS.
WHICH IS A PROBLEM ACROSS THE
DISTRICT.
IS A PROBLEM FOR THE RENTS FOR
THE EMPLOYEES BUT IT'S ALSO A
PROBLEM FOR THE REST OF THE
BUSINESS.
AND WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THIS QUITE
A LOT IN BURBANK IN AN AREA
CALLED MAGNOLIA PARK.
WITH SOME MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
ASKING FOR COMMERCIAL RENT
CONTROL.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS THAT THIS
AND MAKE A PART OF THE SAME
ISSUE OPEN MONTROSE NEAR HERE
WHERE.
THE OLDER BUILDINGS ARE TURNING
OVER THE PERRANCE ART PASSING
THE BUSINESS THOUGH THE
BUILDINGS. TO THE CHILDREN WHO.
REALLY MAY NOT HAVE AS MUCH OF
AN INTEREST OR ONE TO MAXIMIZE
THEIR PROFIT YOU KNOW ICE IS
THEIR RIGHT.
BUT THEN THE SMALL MOM AND POPS
THAT ARE REALLY MOM AND POPS AN
INDEPENDENT SHOPS AND STORES AND
RESTAURANTS JUST CAN'T.
POSSIBLY PAY THE RENT.
HAVE YOU SEEN ANY STRATEGIES
THAT BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN OTHER
AREAS IT EITHER.
THE SHOPPING PARKS THEMSELVES
HAVE EMPLOYED BECAUSE BOTH OF
THESE I BELIEVE HAVE SHOPPING
PARK ASSOCIATIONS I'M NOT SURE
ABOUT BURBANK IN THAT CASE BUT
MONTROSE DOES.
OR THE INDIVIDUAL BUSINESSES OR
AT THE CITY LEVEL HAVE YOU SEEN
ANYTHING --
THAT YOU FEEL HAS BEEN KIND OF
THE THE WAY TO HANDLE THIS.
YEAH I HAVE NOT SEEN ANYTHING
VERY COMPREHENSIVE --
WE TEND TO DEAL ON THE
INDIVIDUAL CLIENT LEVEL.
AND SO -- IN
THAT CASE YOU KNOW WE'RE HELPING
THEM AGO SHE'D THE BEST DEAL
POSSIBLY GET --
OR MAYBE HELPING THEM.
IDENTIFY ALTERNATIVES THEY
HAVEN'T THOUGHT OF BEFORE --
BUT IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW MORE
LIKE ALMOST.
PLANNING APPROACH WE HAVE NOTS.
REALLY WAIT INTO THAT SPACE --
AND THEN SECONDLY IN THE SAME
VEIN.
HAVE YOU SEEN ANY STRATEGIES FOR
THE BRICK AND MORTAR BUSINESSES
THAT ARE FEELING THE CROWD UP
FROM ONLINE BUSINESSES.
THAT YOU THINK A SUCCESSFUL ARE
THERE CERTAIN TYPES OF
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE FOUND WAYS
TO ADAPT --
THAT YOU WOULD THAT YOU
TYPICALLY RECOMMEND TO YOUR
MUSIC SHOP YOUR CLOTHING
RETAILER YOUR BOUTIQUE.
ALL OF THOSE SORTS OF BRICK AND
MORTAR SUTTER ARE FEELING THE
EFFECTS OF THE ON LINE.
GIANTS OUT THERE WILL HAVE A SAY
THE FIRST THING WE ENCOURAGE
THEM TO JUMP INTO THAT POOL AND
MAKE SURE THAT THEY HAVE A
STRONG.
PRESENCE AS WELL.
AND MAYBE THINK ABOUT THEIR
BUSINESS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY THAN THEY MAY HAVE.
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE SPACE THERE'S WELL --
THE OTHER THING I THINK WE'RE
SEEING MORE OF A WOULD BE.
POP UPS IN SHARED SPACE
OPPORTUNITIES THINGS LIKE THAT
SO LOOKING AT YOUR SPACE MORE
EFFICIENT [INAUDIBLE]
RECENTLY THAT.
MAYBE THEY WERE FORCED TO IN THE
PAST AND PARTNER WITH OTHER
BRANDS.
REALLY SORT OF MAXIMIZING
EXPERIENCE TO THEIR CLIENTELE
VERSES.
JUST HOPING THAT THEY SHOW FOR
YOUR ONE OFFER.
YEAH I'M GLAD THAT YOU SAID TO
MAXIMIZE THE EXPERIENCE BECAUSE
JUST ANECDOTALLY AS I'VE
TRAVELED THROUGH THE SPACE AND
HARPER BUSINESSES.
IT SEEMS A THE SHIFT TO OFFERING
EXPERIENCES THAT YOU CAN'T GET
THROUGH ONLINE SHOPPING.
I'M WITH HIGH BOOKSTORES TALK
ABOUT HOW THEY'VE BECOME ANCHORS
YOU KNOW IN AN AGE WITH LONG
PEOPLE CAN BUY ANY BOOK THROUGH
AMAZON BUT THAT THEY BECOME
ANCHORS.
AND THEIR SHOPPING PARKS BECAUSE
THEY OFFER A LOT OF PROGRAMMING --
AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SOCIALIZING AND IT CHANGED A
LITTLE BIT FROM JUST BEING A
PLACE YOU CAN WILL BUY BOOKS TO
BE A PLACE FOR PEOPLE WANT TO GO
BECAUSE THERE'S AUTHORS AND
READINGS AND PANEL DISCUSSIONS
AND THAT SORT OF THING AND AND
TALKED ABOUT HOW THEY I'M ALSO
MAYBE.
GOTTEN BETTER RENT DEALS BECAUSE
THEY WERE ABLE TO SHOW HOW THEY
WERE A DRAW FOR THE OTHER
BUSINESS.
I'M GLAD THAT YOU BROUGHT THAT
UP.
I THINK YOU I HOPE THAT YOU CAN
AS WELL CAN STICK AROUND FOR A
LITTLE BIT LONGER I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE INFORMATION.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OUR NEXT SECTION WHICH IS
FOSTERING INNOVATION IN
INCUBATORS.
AND TO ADDRESS US ON THAT WE
HAVE SANTEE WEBER WHO'S THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FROM GOLDMAN
SACHS -- ONE
THOUSAND TEN THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES.
THANK YOU SHINING.
GOOD MORNING SIMPLY MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AND RADIUS THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INVITATION HERE TODAY
THIS MORNING.
BECAUSE YOU ABOUT THE GOLDMAN
SACHS TEN THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES PROGRAM AND ALSO TO
DISCUSS GROWTH OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES.
MY NAME IS JENNY WEBER AND I'M
THE CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER FOR
COLLEGE ADVANCEMENT AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AT LONG BEACH CA ME
BECAUSE DISTRICT.
AND I OVERSEE THE ECONOMIC AND
WORKFORCE --
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS AT THE
COLLEGE WHICH ALSO INCLUDES A
LOS ANGELES ALONE ALLEY SBDC
NETWORK THAT YOU JUST HEARD FROM.
AND AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE GOLDMAN SACHS TEN
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES I AM
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE LONG BEACH
AND LOS ANGELES SITE --
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR PARTNERS
AT ELLIE CITY COLLEGE.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
PROVIDING AN OVERVIEW OF THE
GOLDMAN SACHS TEN THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES PROGRAM IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SHARE WITH YOU
SOME PROGRAM RESULTS.
SO THE PROGRAM WAS LAUNCHED IN --
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND TEN
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES IS A
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION INITIATIVE
THAT'S FUNDED BY THE GOLDMAN
SACHS FOUNDATION. TO UNLOCK THE
GROWTH AND JOB CREATION
POTENTIAL OF TEN THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES.
THROUGH GREATER ACCESS TO
BUSINESS EDUCATION MENTORS AND
NETWORKS AND FINANCIAL CAPITAL.
IT IS BASED ON THE BROADLY HELD
VIEW THAT LEADING EXPERTS HAVE.
THAT A COMBINATION OF EDUCATION
CAPITAL AND SUPPORT SERVICES
BEST ADDRESSES THE BARRIERS TO
GROWTH FOR SMALL BUSINESSES.
SO IMAGINE AN INTENSIVE
EXECUTIVE BUSINESS MANAGEMENT
EDUCATION PROGRAM.
WITH A WORLD CLASS CURRICULUM
THAT PROVIDES VERY PRACTICAL
HANDS ON LEARNING USING A CASE
STUDY FROM A REAL SMALL BUSINESS.
IN A HIGHLY INTERACTIVE PEER
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT.
WITH INTENSIVE SUPPORT BY A TEAM
OF FACULTY AND BUSINESS ADVISERS
OVER A FOUR MONTH PERIOD.
THIS TEN THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES PROGRAM IS ALL OF
THAT AND IT'S DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY FOR SMALL BUSINESS
UP OWNERS POISED FOR GROWTH.
DOES IN THE PROGRAM COMMITTEE
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED HOURS IN
PERSON SESSIONS COVERING TOPICS
FROM GROWTH AND OPPORTUNITIES TO
MONEY AND METRICS.
THEY ALSO LEARN ABOUT LEADERSHIP
AND Y. CUP COMPANY CULTURE
MATCHES --
MARKETING.
OPERATIONS AND MORE SO THE
HUNDRED HOURS DOESN'T EVEN
INCLUDE THE TIME THEY HAVE TO
SPEND OUTSIDE OF THE CLASSROOM
WORKING ON THEIR GROWTH PLAN
WHICH IS WHAT THEY EMERGE WITH
AT THE END OF THE PROGRAM.
IT'S A VERY POWERFUL AND
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM WHICH I DON'T
NOT ONLY SEEN FIRST HAND --
YOU SEE A NINETY EIGHT POINT
FIVE COMPLETION RATE WHICH
SPEAKS TO HOW OF OF VALUABLE THE
SMALL BUSINESSES FIND THIS
PROGRAM AND IN FACT RECOGNIZE.
A WHAT THEY'RE GETTING FROM THE
PROGRAM.
THE PROGRAM LONG TO SEE COLLEGE
WAS LAUNCHED IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
TEN WORK BUT THE SECOND SIDE OF
MOUNT FOURTEEN SITES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THAT OFFERS A VERY UNIQUE UP
GROWTH PROGRAM FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
COMBINE DEL LA AND LONG BEACH
SITES HAVE GRADUATED OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS WE CALL THEM
SCHOLARS.
WITH AGAIN A NINETY EIGHT POINT
5% COMPLETION RATE THAT I
MENTIONED EARLIER.
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ALSO
BOASTS THE LARGEST ALUMNI GROUP.
ACROSS THE NATION IN THIS
PROGRAM.
THE PROGRAM LOOKS FOR APPLICANTS
WHO GENERALLY MEET THE FOLLOWING
CRITERIA WE LOOK FOR REVENUES
GREATER THAN A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND IN THE MOST RECENT
FISCAL YEAR.
A MINIMUM OF FOUR EMPLOYEES.
YOU HAVE TO BE A CO OWNER OF
OWNER Ó CO OWNER IN THE
BUSINESS.
AND HAVE BEEN IN OPERATION FOR
AT LEAST TWO YEARS.
IN OUR MUCHO RECRUITMENT EFFORTS
WERE VERY FOCUS ON ENSURING THAT
WOMEN SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS AND
THOSE IN THE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES ARE WELL REPRESENTED
IN OUR COHORT.
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT COHORT
DIVERSE CITY BOTH IN INDUSTRIES
AND PARTICIPANTS PROVIDER RICHER
LEARNING EXPERIENCE FOR ALL OF
THE SCHOLARS.
SO YOU'RE PROBABLY WONDERING WHO
ARE THESE TEN THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESS SCHOLARS SO PLEASE
ALLOW ME TO SHARE SOME
STATISTICS.
THERE ENTREPRENEURS FROM ALL
FIFTY STATES AND THESE ARE
NATIONAL STATISTICS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
THEY REPRESENT TOTAL REVENUES OF
OVER NINE BILLION.
DOLLARS WITH OVER A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
EMPLOYED BETWEEN ALL OF THESE
BUSINESSES.
THE PARTICIPANTS COVER ALL AGE
RANGE FROM TWENTY TWO YEARS OF
AGE TO SEVENTY NINE YEARS OF AGE.
THEY HAVE EDUCATIONAL LEVELS
FROM HIGH SCHOOL GED TO GRADUATE
DEGREES. 45% OF THE PARTICIPANTS
ARE WOMEN'S BUSINESS OWNERS.
THE MEDIAN AGE EMPLOYEES AND
REVENUES OF A BUSINESS IS TWELVE
YEARS ELEVEN EMPLOYEES.
AND SEVEN HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND INVOLVING USE
RESPECTIVELY.
GROWTH IN REVENUE AND JOBS ARE
KHIMETRICS USED TO ASSESS THE
IMPACT OF THE PROGRAM SO IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN PROGRESS REPORT
REPORT THAT'S PUBLISHED BY
BABSON COLLEGE.
WHO ACTUALLY DESIGNED THE
NATIONAL CURRICULUM AND IS A
NATIONAL PROGRAM PARTNER AND
THEIR?
NUMBER ONE LEADING
ENTREPRENEURSHIP COLLEGE IN THE
COUNTRY AND RECOGNIZE
INTERNATIONAL.
THE DATA THAT WE COLLECTED FROM
SIX THOUSAND PROGRAM GRADUATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SHOW THAT
THEY PROOF OUTPERFORM THEIR
SMALL BUSINESS PEERS IN GROWING
REVENUES AND CREATING JOB.
HERE ARE SOME OF THE THE STATS I
CAN SHARE WITH YOU.
AFTER -- AT
SIX MONTHS AFTER COMPLETING THE
PROGRAM. 67% OF A OF A SCHOLARS
HAVE INCREASED OUR REVENUE AND
YOU'RE LOOKING AT COMPARING THEM
TO THE NATIONAL AVERAGE OF FORTY
SEVEN PER. 47% HAVE CREATED JOBS.
AND COULD THIS IS COMPARED TO
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE OF TWENTY
FIVE AT THIRTY MONTHS AFTER
COMPLETING THE PROGRAM. 70% HAVE
INCREASED THEIR REVENUES.
AGAIN COMPARED TO THE 47%
NATIONALLY AND THEN 57% HAVE
CREATED JOBS.
SO THE PARTISAN RESULTS CONSISTS
ONLY SHOW THE POSITIVE FAN AND
DURING A FACT THAT THE PROGRAM
HAS ON THE ECONOMY.
THERE IS HOWEVER A COPY OUT OF
THIS -- VERY
NEEDED AN EFFECT PROGRAM IN MY
OPINION.
IT IS NOT INEXPENSIVE TO DELIVER
THIS PROGRAM --
AND DELIVER PROGRAM WAS SUCH
HIGH QUALITY AND AND THANKS TO
THE GENEROUS SUPPORT OF THE
GOLDMAN SACHS FOUNDATION THE
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO OF COURSE
PARTICIPATE IN THE PROGRAM DO
NOT HAVE TO PAY A DYING.
SO THIS IT'S THEY RECEIVE A
SCHOLARSHIP FROM GOLDMAN SACHS
FOUNDATION --
MANY ALSO WONDER WHAT IS THE
SECRET SAUCE TO THIS PROGRAM --
WITH GOLDMAN SACHS SUPPORT
BABSON COLLEGE DESIGNED A
CURRICULUM THAT IS HIGHLY
SCALABLE.
AND REALLY FOCUS ON FOUR KEY
INGREDIENTS.
WE FOCUS ON ENTREPRENEUR GROWTH
AND JOB WE TEND.
PEER TO PEER LEARNING WHERE
PARTICIPANTS BRING THEIR CURRENT
BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES AND
CHALLENGES INTO THE CLASSROOM.
AND THAT THEY CAN APPLY WHAT
THEY LEARN IN CLASS IMMEDIATELY
IN THE OF BUSINESS THE VERY NEXT
DAY WE SEEN THIS HAPPEN OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
THE CURRICULUM IS DIRECTLY
CONNECTED AND INTEGRATED WITH
BUSINESS SUPPORT SERVICES AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACCESS
CAPITAL.
THERE'S ALSO VERY VIGOROUS
MEASURE ANY MEASUREMENT AND
EVALUATION SYSTEM IN PLACE TO
TRACK AND MONITOR THE BUSINESS
OWNERS.
WE CONTINUE TO OUTREACH TO THEM
AND STAY IN TOUCH WITH THEM
THROUGH THE ALUMNI PROGRAM.
WE TEACH BUSINESS OWNERS TO BE
EFFECTIVE EFFICIENT COMPELLING
AND WE TEACH THEM TO WORK ON
THEIR BUSINESS AND KNOCKING THE
OF BUSINESS BECAUSE A LOT OF
TIMES.
AS YOU KNOW ASSEMBLYMAN AREIAS
WHEN YOU.
YOU CAN GET SUCKED INTO ALL THE
MY NEW SHIFTED BUSINESS AND YOU
STOP LOOKING ST SHE WORRIED AT
AT YOUR BUSINESS SO THIS
BUSINESS.
UP TEN THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES
PROGRAM COVERS A LOT OF THINGS
THAT --
REALLY IS NOT NECESSARY WHAT.
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS DON'T KNOW
IT'S REALLY HELPING THEM LOOK AT
THEIR BUSINESSES VERY
DIFFERENTLY AND BY DOING THAT
WITH THIS PROGRAM.
WE REALLY HELP THE BUSINESSES
GROW.
IN LOOKING AT FOSTERING
INNOVATION IN SMALL BUSINESSES --
AND INNOVATION IS A KEY THEME IN
THE PROGRAM --
DATA SHOWS THAT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
AFTER COMPLETING THE PROGRAM
OVER 75% OF OUR GRADUATES HAVE
IMPROVED AN EXISTING PRODUCT OR
SERVICE.
OPENED A NEW LOCATION.
AND OR HAVE AND LAUNCH A NEW
PRODUCT AND SERVICE SO THIS IS
SOME OF THE REASONS WHY THEY
GROW AND CREATE JOBS.
WHAT ARE SOME LESSONS LEARNED --
WE COULD --
THAT WOULD HELP US APPROACH THE
QUESTION OF HOW BEST TO FOSTER
INNOVATION AND INCUBATE SMALL
BUSINESS GROWTH.
NUMBER ONE HAVING A GOOD
PIPELINE IS IMPORTANT TEN
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES RELY
ON THE POOL OF QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS TO FILL A COHORTS.
SO IN OTHER WORDS WE NEED A VERY
STRONG PIPELINE OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
SO THE KEY TO A STRONG PIPELINE
IN BUILDING --
TO HAVE OF SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
IS REALLY BUILDING THE
ENTREPRENEUR ECHOES.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE LARGER
PICTURE PICTURE BECAUSE NOT ONE
SIZE FITS ALL IN THIS PROGRAM IS
NOT.
FOR EVERYONE BECAUSE GROWTH
MEANS DIFFERENT THINGS TO
DIFFERENT BUSINESS OWNERS AND
SOME BUSINESS OWNERS DO NOT WANT
TO GROW.
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS LIKE
THE TEN THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES PROGRAM WORKS.
OUT WE NEED MORE PROGRAMS LIKE
THAT IN THE PIPELINE PROGRAM
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WHO DON'T
MEET THE CRITERIA OF THE TEN
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESS.
THE MICHAEL BUSINESSES THAT YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER --
THAT REQUIRES A LOT OF WORK AND
I THINK THAT NEEDS TO BE MORE
FOCUS ON PROGRAMS LIKE THE TEN
THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES BUT DE
SIGN. FOR THE MICHAEL BUSINESSES
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY NEED TO
HELP TO GET TO A CERTAIN LEVEL.
PLEASE LOOK AT REMOVING BARRIERS --
ECONOMIC INCLUSION AND THEN
EXTENSIVE NETWORK OF RESOURCE
PARTNERS --
HAVING THAT IS VERY IMPORTANT
SAW PARTNERSHIP WITH THE S. B.
D. C. A. S. B. A A LOT OF
CHAMBERS ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA --
AND LOTS OF OTHER PARTNERS MAKES
A DIFFERENCE.
THE OTHER QUESTION IS HOW CAN
GOVERNMENT INCENTIVIZE A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH --
WITH EXISTING TECHNICALS
PROGRAMS THAT THE GOVERNMENT
FUNDS HOW DO WE SET UP ENCOURAGE
AND HELP THE CITIES TO
STREAMLINE AND IMPROVE GET
PLANNING PROCESS.
AND A PERMITTING PROCESS --
MAKING IT MUCH SIMPLER FOR THOSE
US STARTING A BUSINESS AND EVEN
EXISTING BUSINESSES STRUGGLE
WITH THOSE THE PERMITTING AND
PROCESS WHEN THEY ARE.
OPENING ANOTHER LOCATION AND OR
THEY'RE TRYING TO GROW THEIR
BUSINESS.
WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT HOW TO
USE TECHNOLOGIES TO HELP
BUSINESSES LEARN.
SO SUCH AS INTERACTIVE ONLINE
LEARNING BECAUSE TRAFFIC IS A
REAL ISSUE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN LOOKING AT APPS THAT
PROVIDE MEN CHEWING THAT CAN
HELP AN INTRO ENTREPRENEUR OF
THAT THEIR BUSINESS IDEA.
TAKE THEM TO THE STEP BY STEP OF
STARTING AND GROWING A BUSINESS.
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN BECAUSE
ENTREPRENEURS DON'T SLEEP AND
THE UP AND COMING A GENERATION
OF ENTREPRENEURS AND FUTURE
BUSINESS OWNERS OF VERY TECH
SAVVY.
CITIES ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT
STRATEGIES TO BRING RESOURCE
PARTNERS TOGETHER AND ENGAGE
ENTREPRENEURS TO GROW THE ECO
SYSTEM --
THE ECO SYSTEM GROWING ECO
SYSTEM HAS TO BE DRIVEN BY
ENTREPRENEURS.
THE CITIES HAVE TO TAKE RISK AND
PARTNER WITH ENTREPRENEURS IN
WAYS THAT SERVES THE COMMUNITIES
SO AN EXAMPLE IS THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH.
WHO IS CURRENTLY TESTING
APPROACHES AND STRATEGIES AS
PART OF THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
BLUEPRINT?
IN BUILDING ECO SYSTEM THEY'VE
PARTNER WITH AN ENTREPRENEUR TO
BUILT A CO WORKING SPACE.
CITY OWNED PROPERTY FORM THAT
WAS FORMALLY AN RTA PROPERTY
WHICH ALSO OFF --
IS GOING TO OFFER ON THE
TECHNICAL SMALL BUSINESS ON THE
SMALL BUSINESS TECHNICAL SYSTEM
NETWORK FORCE PROGRAMS THAT
LUMBER CITY COLLEGE OFFERS.
SO THE PAPER POP UP PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIP IS VERY IMPORTANT --
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENTS NEW SMALL BUSINESS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANT EXPANSION
PROGRAM.
THAT ADJUSTED TOYS MENTION
EARLIER IS A BIG STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION.
LEVERAGING FEDERAL FUNDS TO
INCREASE THAT CAPACITY ACROSS
THE STATE IN ASSISTING SMALL
BUSINESSES.
OF ALL LEVELS THAT IS A VERY
IMPORTANT I THINK BREAKTHROUGH
FOR AT THE STATE LEVEL.
AND AND I WANT --
TO RECOGNIZED JESSE TOURS HE WAS
ACTUALLY VERY INSTRUMENTAL AND
CHAMPIONING THIS PROGRAM BEHIND
THE SCENES IN MAKING THIS HAPPEN.
AND ALSO A VERY FAINT BECAUSE MY
THANKS TO ADAM ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
QUICKSILVER AND CERVANTES FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
SOME OF THE COMMUNITIES VERY
EXCITED.
ANOTHER QUESTION IS WHAT ROLE
CAN GOVERNMENT PLAY IN
ENCOURAGING MORE INNOVATION.
AND FINDING NEW WAYS OF GETTING
FUNDING TO SMALL BUSINESSES
THEIR PROGRAMS LIKE KIVA DOT COM
THAT CAN HELP TO BUILD A SMALL
OF BRAND NEW UN ENTREPRENEURS
CREDIT SCORES AND AND REPUTATION.
AND THEN OF FUND BOX WHICH WORKS
TO GET.
OF FUNDING TO SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS VERY QUICKLY --
AND THEN ENCOURAGING CITIES TO
ENGAGE WITH THE KAUFMAN
FOUNDATIONS MAYOR'S CONFERENCE
ON ENTREPRENEURSHIP WHICH BRINGS
TOGETHER MAYORS WITH
ENTREPRENEURS ECHOES.
BUILDERS RESEARCHERS AND POLICY
EXPERTS TO DISCOVER WAYS TO
BUILD A MEASURE HEALTHY
ENTREPRENEUR ECO SYSTEM --
WITH ENTREPRENEURSHIP AT IT AT
AN ALL TIME LOW THIS ISSUES EVEN
MORE URGENT FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE SMALL BUSINESSES CREATE
663% OF NET NEW JOBS AND IS 99%
OF THE U. S. EMPLOYER FIRMS --
LASTLY WHAT I WANT TO MENTION
THE ISSUE OF WORKFORCE.
OUT OF QUALIFY --
READY WORKFORCE IT'S AN ISSUE
THAT COMES UP AGAIN AND AGAIN
WITHOUT SMALL BUSINESSES --
HIRING AND TRAINING QUALIFIED
WORKERS UP.
HAVING THEM OF FINDING THEM AND
KEEPING THEM IT'S A BAKER VERY A
TO THEIR GROWTH SO THAT'S AN
ISSUE THAT WE ALSO NEED TO LOOK
AN ADDRESS AND FINDING WAYS TO
PARTNER WITH ALL.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND NOW
EDUCATE [INAUDIBLE]
TIONS AND ALSO THE UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO START ONLY.
FEELING THAT PIPELINE.
I WOULD LIKE TO END THIS REPORT
FROM A QUOTE FROM THE CENTER FOR
AMERICAN ON PARTNERSHIP THAT
SUMS UP THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENTREPRENEURSHIP IN [INAUDIBLE]
STATES.
ENTREPRENEURSHIP IS CENTRAL TO
THE AMERICAN IDENTITY.
THE AMERICAN EXPERIMENT ITSELF
IS A PROFOUND ENTREPRENEUR I'M
TO TAKE.
GROUNDED IN THE FRONTIER SPIRIT
OF FREEDOM ADVENTURE AND SELF
RELIANCE AND A COMMITMENT.
OUT DEMOCRATIC VALUES OFFENDERS
AND COOPERATION.
ENTREPRENEURS PAST AND PRESENT
PLAY A PROMINENT ROLE IN OUR
POPULAR CULTURE AND THE ABILITY
TO STRIKE OUT ON ONE'S OWN IS
WOVEN INTO OUR NATION'S SOCIAL
FABRIC.
IF WE'D LOSE THE CENTRAL.
AND THIS AND YOU KNOW MY MY
SENSE OF ALL OF THIS IS.
IF WE LOSE THE CENTRAL AMERICAN
IDENTITY TOO MANY COUNTRIES ONLY
HOPE TO REPLICATE AND SOMEWHAT
TRYING TO REPLICATE ESPECIALLY
IN ASIA.
WE LOSE OUR COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGE GLOBAL.
SO THANK YOU.
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY.
YOU CAN IS WEBER I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TALKING ABOUT --
WHAT YOU SEE IS SOME OF THE --
ROLES FOR GOVERNMENT --
IN THE FUNCTIONING OF SMALL
BUSINESS ENTREPRENEURS THAT'S
VERY HELPFUL FOR THE COMMITTEE --
I ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR TALKING
ABOUT ON THE CITY'S CITIES ROLE
AS THE ONES WHO ARE DOING THE
LOCAL PERMITTING.
I WHEN I WAS A COUNCIL MEMBER
GLENDALE WE SPEND QUITE A BIT OF
TIME WORKING ON STREAMLINING OUR
PRACTICES AND THROUGH OUR
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
SET UP -- A
CONCIERGE PROGRAM FOR BUSINESSES
WANT TO OPEN IN THE CITY THAT
WAS SIX SO SUCCESSFUL THE CITY
SPREAD IT.
ACROSS THE CITY OUT OF THE RDAS
AND THEN CONTINUED IT BEYOND
BILL LOSS OF RDAS.
AND IT'S INTERESTING ALSO THAT
YOU DIDN'T THE RDAS THE
REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
THEY DON'T EXIST NOW CALIFORNIA
FORTUNE AND SO TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO FOSTER THOSE PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS --
AT A TIME WHEN A LOT OF CITIES
FIND THEIR BUDGETS STRETCHED.
AND SOMETIMES DON'T VALUE ON
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ROLE WITHIN
THEIR CITIES ESPECIALLY IF
THEY'RE SMALLER CITY OR DON'T
HAVE THE FINANCES TO FUND THAT
IS A REAL CHALLENGE FOR CITIES.
AND WANTING IF YOU HAVE ANY
THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW IF THERE IS A
STATE ROLE. TO ASSIST THE CITY'S
WITHOUT ROLE OR WHETHER IT'S
REALLY INCUMBENT ON INDIVIDUAL
CITIES.
BASED ON THEIR OWN ECONOMY.
THEIR OWN LOCATION TO KIND OF
FIND THEIR WAY THEMSELVES --
AND MAYBE TRY TO EMPLOY THEIR
CREATIVITY IF THEY'RE FINANCES
AREN'T THEIR DEATH HIGHER AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TEAM IF YOU
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS ABOUT THAT --
YES I DO SO THAT'S A VERY
INTERESTING --
THING WITH A RESOLUTION OF THE
RGA THAT A LOT OF CITY SIT ON
PROPERTIES THAT THEY DON'T
BELIEVE YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH.
BUT I I YOU KNOW HAVE BEING --
FROM A PUBLIC AGENCY IS WHILE I
UNDERSTAND THE LIMITATIONS AND
RESOURCES PUBLIC AGENCIES FROM
CITIES HAVE.
IN BUILDING OUT OF A LOT OF
PROGRAMMING AND A FRIEND
OFFERINGS OF THE COMMUNITIES ONE
OF THE INTERESTING THINGS THAT I
SEE.
THAT -- I I
WOULD LIKE TO ENCOURAGE MORE
CITIES TO DO IS --
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH WAS PART
OF THE BLOOMBERG'S A AWARD
INNOVATION AWARD AND WHAT THEY
DID AS PART OF THAT WAS THE PUT
OUT AN RFP.
UP TO THE COMMUNITY TO TO
REQUEST FOR IDEAS AND IS YOU
KNOW MODELS TO HELP THE CITY
ACTIVATE.
OF PHYSICAL SPACE SAYS TO EXPAND
AND GROW THE ENTREPRENEUR ECO
SYSTEM THEY THEY WERE JUST
CURIOUS TO SEE WHAT KIND OF
IDEAS ARE OUT THERE WHO'S
WILLING TO WORK.
WITH US AND HOW COULD WE MAYBE --
LOOK AT DOING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT AND OF ONE OF THE
REASONS HE DID THAT'S BECAUSE AT
SOME R. D. EIGHT PROPERTY THEY
WERE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO HOW DID --
LOOK WITHIN I MENTIONED OF THE
PROJECT IN THAT CITY OF LONG
BEACH WHERE --
THEY HAD ALREADY A PROPERTY.
AND BECAUSE OF WE WERE IN THERE
TO DELIVER SPD SERVICES THOUGHT
THE CITY PROVIDES THE HARDWARE
WHICH IS THE BUILDING WE PROVIDE
AT THE OF THE SOFTWARE WHICH IS
THE DIFFERENCE SERVICES.
BUT WE DIDN'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO REALLY OPERATE IT --
YOU KNOW EIGHT TO FIVE MONDAY
THROUGH FRIDAY OR MAYBE ON
WEEKENDS.
SO ONE OF THE IDEAS IS HOW DO WE
DO THAT IF WE CAN FIGURE OUT A
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP --
AND WE WERE ABLE TO FIND A AN
ENTREPRENEUR IN IN LA BLANK
SPACES THEY ARE WILLING TO COME
IN AND OPERATE --
LOCAL WORKING SPACE.
AND WE STRUCTURED SO THAT WE ARE
NOT IN THE WAY OF A FOR PROFIT
ENTITY --
GENERATING YOU KNOW.
RUNNING THAT --
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE EXPERTS IT
TEASES IN RUNNING A CO WORKING
SPACE -- AS
PARTNERS THE CITY THEM PROVIDED
SOME INCENTIVES FOR THE
ENTREPRENEUR AND WE ARE GOING TO
BE LOCATED IN [INAUDIBLE]
THIS.
BEING ABLE TO OFFER DIFFERENT
ATTRACT SMALL SMALL BUSINESSES
TO THE CITY OF LONG BEACH THAT'S
AN EXPERIMENT THAT WE ARE
UNDERTAKING IN LONG BEACH.
I THINK IT HAS A LOT OF PROMISE --
I'VE SEEN OTHER PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP WORK --
IT'S IT'S OF THE OF THE PRIVATE
SECTOR HAS RESOURCES IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF HOW DO WE UTILIZE.
AND HOW DO WE FLYING WAYS TO
WORK WITH THEM IT'S VERY HARD
FOR THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO WORK
WITH CITIES BECAUSE OF SO MUCH
BUREAUCRACY.
IT TAKES PROBABLY TEN TIMES AS
LONG TO DO SOMETHING AND NOT ALL
ENTREPRENEURS HAVE THE STOMACH
TO DO THAT BUT SOME OF THEM OUT
THERE.
ARE -- AND
IT'S ABOUT BUILDING COMMUNITIES
ABOUT A BUILDING THE ACTUAL
SYSTEM AND A LOT OF SMALL
BUSINESSES AS WE'RE FINDING.
THROUGH --
THE TEN THOUSAND SMALL
BUSINESSES 65% OF THEM I'VE
ACTIVELY ENGAGE WITH THE CA. TO
SHERRY THE WEBSITE --
SOMEWHERE WHERE PEOPLE CAN LOOK
TO GET THE INFORMATION THAT
SHARED WITH US TODAY.
YES -- SO.
IF ANYONE'S INTERESTED IN
APPLYING FOR THE GOLDMAN SACHS
TEN THOUSAND SMALL BUSINESSES
THEY CAN GO TO WWW.
SO CAO TEN K. SP DOT COM.
SO THAT'S S. O. C. A. L. ONE
ZERO K. SP DOT COM.
AND THEN IF HE I MEAN --
IF YOU WOULD MIND I JUST LIKE TO
COMMENT ON AN EARLY OF YOU HAD --
AND REMEMBER REYES UNIT OF
TALKED ABOUT I THINK IT WAS
FRIEDMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE BRICK AND MORTAR
BUSINESSES COME MEETING WITH THE
E. COMMERCE.
THAT IS -- A
THAT IS A BIG A CONCERN FOR A
LOT OF SMALL BUSINESSES PART OF
WHAT ABOUT PAT HAD MENTIONED
ALSO IS.
TO JOIN FOR THE E. COMMERCE
BANDWAGON AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
PROGRAMS OUT THERE --
95% OF THE WORLD MARKET IS
OUTSIDE OF THE U..
IT'S A REALLY BIG OPPORTUNITY
FOR SMALL BUSINESS TO GROW --
AND BUT A LOT OF SMALL BUSINESS
I'M NOT LOOKING AT THOSE OP.
SWEENEY PROGRAMS TO HELP THEM
LEARN HOW TO DO BUSINESS --
GLOBALLY AND THEN THE OTHER WAY --
TO AND YOU HAVE ELUDED TO THIS
AS WELL IS TO COMPETE IS BY
BUILDING COMMUNITY.
AND A LOT OF THAT CAN BE DONE
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA.
IT'S ONE OF THE KEYS TO DOING
THAT -- BUT
ALLOWS SMALL BUSINESSES DON'T
KNOW HOW TO UTILIZE SOCIAL MEDIA
TO TO PROMOTE THEIR BUSINESS AND
IT'S NOT JUST PROMOTING ITS ALSO
BUILDING.
PRESENCE AND BUILDING COMMUNITY.
AND SO THAT'S A VERY MUCH NEEDED
SERVICES WHILE [INAUDIBLE]
THINKING [INAUDIBLE]
YOU.
YOU'RE GOING TO SHIFT GEARS AND
MOVE ON NOW TO HEAR FROM SOME OF
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES I'M FIRST
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR ACTUALLY --
OKAY PAM YOU'RE UP THERE SO WILL
BRING UP PAN FROM THAT'S OKAY
COME ON OUT JUST THE GUY AND
THAT'S OKAY TO HAMPER FROM HIS
[INAUDIBLE]
HIGHER.
AND I SHOULD KNOW MIA
[INAUDIBLE]
HERE [INAUDIBLE]
AND IN A REMOTE AREA.
GREAT WELL FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR A HALF ME TO
SPEAK TODAY --
AND I REALLY WANT TO COMPLEMENT
THE THREE SPEAKERS WHO SPOKE
BEFORE ME BECAUSE AS A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER WHO'S BEEN HERE
FOR THIRTY FIVE YEARS.
I'VE HEARD THESE THREE PEOPLE
SAY THINGS I'M GOING I COULD USE
THAT TODAY I HOPE THAT THIS IS
GREAT TO KNOW ABOUT IT --
UNDERTAKING MY BIGGEST PROBLEM.
IS RENTS IT'S OUR COMPANIES RENT
IT'S MY EMPLOYEES RAN SO RENT
BESIDES BEING JUST A WONDERFUL
MUSICAL WHICH WE WORKED ON IT IS
ALSO ONE OF MY BIGGEST PROBLEMS --
I OWN THIS COMPANY WITH MY
HUSBAND JIM MALEATE THAT'S JIM
THE PIC THERE.
WE STARTED NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE
PERM PERMANENT BY WHAT.
WE BOTH WENT TO HER CAR DESIGN
WHICH IS NOW IN POWER GREEN.
WE'VE LIVED IN GLENDALE ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT THIRTY THREE SINCE
EIGHTEEN BEFORE [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIT DARK THE COMPANY WE ARE
BOB BURBANK AIRPORT WERE IN
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT --
THIRTY NINE WE'VE BEEN THEIR
OVERT FIVE YEARS SO I THINK IS
ANYBODY HERE WHO KNOWS AMOUNT
FIVE MORE THAN POT THAT BILL --
ARE RED CURLY IS TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND A MONTH AT OUR CAMP
CHARGES ARE TEN THOUSAND MONTH.
SO THE PROBLEM ISN'T JUST
TALKING ABOUT RENT IT'S ALSO
TALKING ABOUT CAMERA CHARGES
SINCE OUR COMMUNITY.
AREA MAINTENANCE CHARGES AND
I'LL GET INTO THAT A LITTLE BIT
MORE IN A MINUTE.
SO WHAT OUR COMPANY DOLLARS ON
THE HOUSE VIEWPOINT SUITING UP.
OKAY.
I HAVE I HAVE VISUALS ITEM WE
READ PROPS TO THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY AND WE'VE SHIPPED OUR
PROPS TO EVERY CONTINENT.
I PROJECTS GOING ON IN CHINA
RIGHT NOW I'M CERTAINLY.
IN CANADA A LOT AND I'VE DONE
PRICE [INAUDIBLE]
ANTARCTICA.
TO SO PROP SO THE ITEMS IN A
FILM OR TV SHOW THAT HELP TELL
THE STORY AND SO WE HAVE A STORY
COMING IN HERE --
WHAT WE'RE SEEING ARE PROPS THAT
WE JUST READ IT TO TOM HANKS
WHERE THESE PROPS IN A MOVIE
CALLED GREYHOUND?
WE CRISIS TOOK DIRECTOR SURRIDGE
KNEE LA VERY MODELING THERE YOU
GO I WANTED TO SHOW HOW GLENDALE
AND THE FORTY THIRD DISTRICT
IT'S REALLY THE CENTER OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT.
SO WE HAVE EXAMPLES OF THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT WE'VE MADE AND
WE'VE USE.
NOW ALL THAT'S VERY GOOD.
YOU CAN WEAR IT IF YOU WANT.
SO ON I WANT TO TELL YOU A
LITTLE BIT THAT'S WHAT I DID
THAT'S WHAT I GRANT.
SOMEONE IT SHOULD YOU LITTLE BIT
ABOUT ARE STATIC CALLED I WANTED
ME TO MY STAFF MEMBERS JOHN.
THE GENTLEMAN ON THE LEFT IS
HERE KNOWLEDGE.
ISN'T IT THAT WHEN.
YOU LOOK OUT WITH TWO OTHER
PEOPLE IN BROWN EYES.
RENTS FROM A POLL WORKER SISTER
HE WAS PROBABLY NUMBER WILLOWS
BRAND OF ANYBODY WHO WORKS FOR
ME.
THE GENTLEMAN ON THE RIGHT JOHN
HE'S SEVENTY YEARS OLD RETIRED
FROM LOCALLY.
AND HERE IS WHY BOTHER HOW IS
BACK IN THE NINETEEN NINETY TAX
LOSSES BORDER.
KRISTIN I SHE'S PART OF HISTORY
PRIOR FOR THREE YEARS THERE'S
JUST A FIVE YEARS OLD.
SHE HAS FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
STOOD AT AND SHE WASN'T AROUND
TROLL A MINUTE SANTA WAS WITH
MAY.
IT'S NOT OSCAR THE CAT SIR
CATHARINE THE PICTURE.
NEVER THINK ABOUT IRAN.
SWIM I'M BASED TO KNOW LANDLORDS
ARE BOTH.
BOB DOESN'T LOOK AT IRAQ BUTTON
DO DAHLE.
SO NEXT WEEK HE IS REMOVED LOS
VEGAS.
BOB WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT ONE
OF THE FILMS THAT WE WORKED ON A
GREYHOUND THAT WAS THE ONE WE
JUST SAW THE EXAMPLES FROM AND
YOU CAN SEE THE HATS THERE THOSE
ARE OUR CREW.
PAINTING OF TAPS.
IS PRODUCED BY APPROVED JURORS
FINANCED ATWATER CAPITAL IN A
DEAL BROKERED CA HEY IT IS
DISTRIBUTED BY SONY.
AND ITS FILMING IN LOUISIANA NOW
SHIP AWARE YOU MAY.
ARE WE TOLD.
FROM THE MANY COMPLAINTS.
NOT UP WHAT ALBERTO. TO WHO IS
FINDING IT.
THIS IS THE CHAIR OF THEIR
WEBSITE PERSON LOS ANGELES.
THIS UPS OR IS THERE ADDRESS.
I'M GONNA VENTURE TO SAY THE
MONTHLY RENT IT PROBABLY LESSEN
MY THIRTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
LOUISIANA OUT WHERE WE JUST DID
THIS PROJECT THEY ARE FOR A UP
2405% REBATE ON RENTALS IN THEIR
AREA TAX REBATE.
AND THE CYCLE WHAT IT FELT LOOK
LIKE IF YOUR COMPANY EN LA
RENTING LOUISIANA.
THIS IS WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
ON THE RIDE WOULD BE MY INVOICE
ON AROUND THESE FIGURES BECAUSE
I CAN'T GO FAR.
ON THE RIGHT YOU SEE MY INVOICE
FOR TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND THEN
YOU'LL SEE WE RENTED TO A
COMPANY IN LOUISIANA.
WHO THEN HAS TO GO THROUGH A
PASSED THROUGH COMPANY CALLED
SEE CO ES?
THAT PASSED THROUGH THE OPENING
ADDS ON A 5% SPEED.
PLUS THEY ON ON A 10% LULU TAN
ATTACKS.
SO DOING AMOUNT THAT REALLY WHAT
THEY'RE PAYING THEY'RE GETTING
IS ABOUT A 30% REBATE BACK.
NOT WHO IS CCO AUS SEA COS IS MY
NEIGHBOR CASTING GROUP HUGE
PAYROLL COMPANY ONE OF THE BEST.
AND THEY HAVE A DIVISION CALLED
CAST AND CREW ON SAID THAT
OFFERS.
AT THAT OPERATES AS A PASS
THROUGH COMPANY THEIR BRICK AND
MORTAR LOCATIONS AND MANY MANY
STATES.
THEIR CORPORATE OFFICES IN
BURBANK WHICH IS ABOUT TWO MILES
FROM ME.
AND THEY EMPLOY A LITTLE OVER
SIX HUNDRED PEOPLE.
SO THIS FILM DOING LOUISIANA THE
MONEY COME THROUGH ATWATER
VILLAGE.
IT GOES TO BURBANK THAT THEN
PAYS ME AND THEN WE SHIPPED TO
LOUISIANA [INAUDIBLE]
OUR THIS ONE ARE ONE OF THE
ISSUES I TALKED ABOUT WHICH IS A
BIG PROBLEM.
OUR OUR CAMERA CHARGES
COMMUNALLY REMAIN IS CHARGES
WHICH ARE CLEARLY HALF OF WHAT
AROUND TENANTS --
THIS IS A LETTER I GOT YESTERDAY
TELLING ME THAT THE CAMP CHARGES
ARE GOING UP.
OF I WILL READ IT TO GET THE
AUDIO VIDEO TELL ME THAT THERE
ARE NOT BIRDS THEY CAN PUT IN
THE SUBTEXT FOR WHAT I WOULD
WANT TO SAY ABOUT MY FEELINGS
ABOUT THIS LETTER. ONE OF THE
BIG ISSUES WE DEAL WITH ALSO
MONTHS OUR CLIENTS YOUR QUESTION
KNOWS CAMP CHARGES COME FROM A
BUSINESS IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT OR
FROM THE LANDLORD WHO.
YOU KNOW THE LANDLORD THE
LANDLORD DOESN'T YEAH --
IF THERE ARE THINGS WHERE HAVE
YOU FOR THOSE WHO PEOPLE HERE
WHO MAY NOT KNOW ARMY CAMP
CHARGES ARE PROPERTY TAXES
INSURANCE BECAUSE BUILDING
MAINTENANCE ALL THOSE KINDS OF
ISSUES.
I WANT ANY OTHER PROBLEMS REALLY
AFFECTS SMALL BUSINESSES READ IN
THE AREA MEN.
IS THE CAPITALIST LOCATE
RESTRICTED WORD.
I AM NO PROBLEMS MY BUSINESS
SYNDICATE THIS.
IS I'M TOTALLY O. WITHOUT LOVING
IS NOT.
BUT THE TWO CAT BUSINESS AND
THEY COME TO HEAR BILLS WERE.
THIS IS LIKE A HIGH AM LOCATED
AND YOU'LL SEE FROM THERE
DISTRICT HERE THOUGH BLUE AREAS.
THAT.
BUSINESS IS TO DO WHAT YOU ARE
LOCATED.
THEY CAN GO ARE OFTEN MUCH MORE
MONEY PER SQUARE FOOT CAN AFFORD
TO PAY.
OF ONE OF THE BECAUSE I KNOW A
LONGTIME GLOBAL AFFECTS.
THEY HAD TO MOVE BECAUSE OF ONE
DOLLAR A SQUARE FOOT BECAUSE
THEY CAN GET IT FROM CANNABIS.
SO IT IS AN ISSUE WE DEAL WITH
LAST NIGHT I WAS TRYING TO SEE
IF I COULD FIND A LARGER
BUILDING IN OUR AREA.
AND EVERYTHING THAT I LOOKED AT
THAT WAS OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
FEET SAID ZONE FOR CANNABIS ZONE
FOR CANNABIS I'M NOT CAN BE ABLE
TO COMPETE WITH THAT RANT.
SO I WOULD SAY WHAT WE CAN DO
NOW FOR SMALL BUSINESS --
IS TO ADD A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
TO THE CALIFORNIA FILM
COMMISSION BOARD TODAY AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE BETWEEN TO HELP ON
ON THEIR THERE REALLY NEEDS TO
BE A CAMP CHARTER FOR REFORM.
AND I WOULD LOVE TO SEE CAPS
THING CAM CHARGES --
RENT CONTROL IN BURBANK AND
GLENDALE STORE EMPLOYEES CAN
AFFORD A DECENT PLACE TO LIVE
WOULD BE A BIG HELP.
AND THAT REALIZES PRODUCTION
GOING TO OTHER STATES IS NOT
ABOUT THEM BEING LURED AWAY.
THOUGHT ABOUT THEM CHOOSING NOT
TO FILM HERE AND YOU CAN'T FILM
EVERYTHING HERE SOMETIMES.
LIKE THE PROJECT WE WORKED ON A
GREYHOUND IT JUST MADE SENSE FOR
THEM TO FILL THAT THERE BECAUSE
IT ST NAUTICAL.
SO THAT'S WHAT I HAVE TO TELL
YOU ABOUT TODAY RENTS ARE A BIG
PROBLEM FOR ME IN MY STAFF.
YOU MENTIONED LAURIE MENTIONED
EARLIER SOME THINGS HE WAS
SAYING IN AND MONTROSE AND I
TOTALLY UNDERSTAND THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING.
THINK [INAUDIBLE]
LOOK.
OKAY NEXT MOVE TO BETTY JO I'M --
TYPICALLY FROM BOARD PRESIDENT
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
[INAUDIBLE]
MORNING.
WELL I LOVE OUR TOPIC --
OPPORTUNITIES AND CHALLENGES.
AND I THINK AS A SMALL BUSINESS
PERSON SOMETIMES WE TEND TO PUT
THE CHALLENGES.
AND GET BOGGED DOWN IN THAT AREA
VERSUS THE OPPORTUNITIES SO I
WANTED TO START TODAY BY
THANKING YOU.
UP FIRST OF ALL I HAVE --
A HISTORY OF HAVING WORKED FOR
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCACY SO MAYBE
I HAVE A LONG MEMORY BUT IN THE
YEAR.
TWO THOUSAND THE ASSEMBLY PASSED
A RESOLUTION THAT PROCLAIMED
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS DAY.
AND EVERY YEAR THANKS TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS --
WE HAVE HONORED SMALL BUSINESSES
IN YOUR DISTRICT.
AND THE TWO OF YOU DID THAT THIS
YEAR I THINK HIM ASSEMBLYMAN
FRIEDMAN'S.
HAVE A TYPICAL SMALL BUSINESS
SITUATION THAT THE LAST MINUTE
THEY COULDN'T ATTEND
[INAUDIBLE]
BUT SIMON RAYOS YOU LOOK VERY
ATTRACTIVE IN THIS AND WE TRY
AND LIMIT IT TO SEVENTY FIVE OUT
OF THE HUNDRED AND TWENTY BUT
USUALLY RUN SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
EIGHTY AND EIGHTY FIVE ARE.
THE OTHER THING I WANT.
TO SHARE WITH YOU IS BY
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS FIRST.
WE UP PUT THIS TOGETHER AND WE
WILL FOR ME SHIP.
FOR ANY LOCAL CHAMBER IN THE
INDIVIDUAL SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
ANYBODY THAT WANTS TO PROMOTE
SMALL BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE BACK PAGES FOR YOU TO
PUT WHATEVER YOU WANT.
IN THAT PARTICULAR DIRECTION.
BECAUSE WE THINK THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH EDUCATION.
ON WHO SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND I WAS SITTING THERE AND I
WAS THINKING OF YOU KNOW I THINK
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE IN THE
DEFINITION OF ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
AND SMALL BUSINESS AND I THINK
PROBABLY EACH OF SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE OUR OWN
DEFINITIONS AND I THINK THAT
MAKES IT NOT ONLY HARD TO
GOVERNANCE IT HIT MAKES IT HARD
TO HELP US IN IN THAT DIRECTION.
BUT I DO WANT TO TALK I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT ADVOCACY I WANT TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE HISTORY.
IN THE NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
WHITE HOUSE CONFERENCE ON SMALL
BUSINESS --
I WAS ASKED.
TO OF WORK AT THE STATE LEVEL
RATHER THAN THE FEDERAL LEVEL ON
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATES.
AND THAT WAS ONE OF THE BEST
DECISIONS I EVER MADE SO I'M
REALLY FOCUSED ON I CALIFORNIA.
I KNOW THAT THERE'S A LOT GOING
ON AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND I
GET ALL KINDS OF QUESTIONS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE THE SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY DOESN'T HAVE.
THE VOLUME OF PEOPLE TO WORK ON
ALL THE ISSUES SO WHAT WE DO IS
FOLLOW THE WHITE HOUSE DELEGATES --
WE HAVE.
ELEVEN ISSUES COMMITTEES THAT
ARE COMPOSED OF SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS [INAUDIBLE]
THEY DETERMINE.
STATEWIDE WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
WORK ON IN THAT AREA.
SO LET ME TALK TO YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT HOW.
BUT THEY ARE THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE IS WORKERS COMP REFORM.
AND AS YOU I THINK BOTH KNOW WE
DO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS --
ON HOW TO MAKE IT BETTER AND MY
NUMBER ONE RECOMMENDATION ON
WORKERS COMP REFORM.
IS WE'D LOVE TO THINGS I GUESS
[INAUDIBLE]
WE WE KNOW WORKER'S COMP OF
THANKS TO THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION.
IS THE NUMBER ONE REASON FOR THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY GROWING TO
THE CANDIDATES.
AND SO WE NEED ENFORCEMENT IN IN
THAT DIRECTION [INAUDIBLE]
AND WE ALSO NEED --
TO LOOK AT THAT WHAT WORKS FOR
BIG BUSINESS DOESN'T ALWAYS WORK
FOR SMALL BUSINESS IN THE AREA
OF WORKERS COMP.
AND I THINK THEY'RE I THINK
WE'RE MAKING SOME PROGRESS IN
THAT.
BUT I THINK WE HAVEN'T REALLY --
DONE ANYTHING THAT SHOWS SO
MAYBE ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
THINK ABOUT IS ENFORCEMENT OF
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY.
AND MAYBE YOU THINK ABOUT THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY YEAR GIVING THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S. TO GO AFTER
WORKERS CONTEST DRIVE.
THAT'S NOT BEING USED MAYBE
THERE'S A BETTER WAY.
AND WE'D BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU ON MAKING THAT HAPPEN.
WE DON'T WANT THE GOOD GUYS.
THAT ARE.
DOING IT RIGHT. TO BE PENALIZED
FROM A COMP COMPETITION
STANDPOINT BY THE GUYS THAT ARE
UNDERGROUND SO WE FEEL VERY
STRONGLY ABOUT WORKING ON THE
WORKERS BECAUSE ISSUE AND
PARTICULARLY THE FRAUD.
THE NUMBER ONE CONCERN OF MINE
IS A BILL WE HAVE --
IN.
ACTUALLY IT'S STILL IN THE
SENATE I AM AFRAID THAT MEANS
IT'S DEAD BUT I HAVEN'T GIVEN UP --
TAXES ARE A BIG ISSUE.
AND THERE'S A GREAT DEAL OF
CONCERN ABOUT --
THE REPEAL OF THE SPLIT TAX ROLL --
WE KNOW THAT THERE IS A PROPOSAL
FOR A 10% BUSINESS TAX.
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN
DISCUSSION FOR SEVERAL YEARS FOR
SALES TAX ON SERVICES.
AND IT GOES ON AND ON BUT I
THINK MY MAJOR CONCERN.
IS ON WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS DOING --
MY SOURCE OF INFORMATION IS THE
U. S. CHAMBER --
SMALL BUSINESS COUNCIL.
THEY TELL ME THAT --
WHEN THE RIGS COME OUT ON TAX
REFORM?
THAT ONLY S. AND C. CORPORATIONS
WILL BE ALLOWED TO TAKE BUSINESS
EXPENSES.
THIS WE'LL BE A DISASTER FOR
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE ONLY 17%.
OF OUR SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
INCORPORATED.
AND PART OF IT IS THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE EMPLOYEES IN I
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND IF WE COULD.
IF YOU COULD HELP US --
AND WE THINK S. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN WOULD HELP.
BECAUSE THE NUMBER ONE REASON
THEY DON'T INCORPORATE IS
BECAUSE OF THE EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS MINIMUM FRANCHISE TAG.
SO THIS WOULD MAKE A SLIDING
SCALE --
MICRO BUSINESSES WHICH ARE
IMPORTANT TO THE ECONOMY.
WOULD PAY TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
MINIMUM. FOR TWO MINUTES FOUR
HUNDRED SIX HUNDRED EIGHT
HUNDRED SO YOU WOULD ONLY PAY
THE EIGHT HUNDRED IF YEAR GROSS
REVENUES FOR FIFTEEN MILLION OR
MORE -- IT'S
TYPICAL THAT IS BOGGED DOWN AND
APPROPRIATIONS --
I THINK YOU NEED TO EDUCATORS
HOW TO GET THINGS THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF CPA'S AND WE GET
BOGGED DOWN WITH THE THE
FINANCIAL END OF IT [INAUDIBLE]
BUT HERE'S A STATISTIC THAT I
WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT AND DO
THE ARITHMETIC.
IF CURRENTLY ONLY 17% OF SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS.
ARE INCORPORATED AS EITHER S. OR
C. CORPORATIONS.
AND THEY PAY EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
IF WE COULD SWITCH THAT. 240%
PAID TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS. 20%
PAID. FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS 20%
PAID SIX HUNDRED DOLLARS AND 20%.
PAID EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS.
THAT'S A LOT OF IT EXCESS TAXES
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT WE DON'T WE DON'T STAND A
CHANCE IT SEEMS LIKE EXPLAINING
THIS AND AND PEOPLE BUYING IN
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE.
THE FINANCIAL PEOPLE WITH ALL
THE CHARTS AND FIGURES IN IN
THAT DIRECTION SO MAYBE YOU CAN
HELP US IN THAT AREA --
THE OTHER VERY I WANNA TALK
ABOUT HIS PROCUREMENT --
WE'VE SUPPORTED SP.
ONE OF WHICH WAS A
TRANSPORTATION BILL.
AND WE STILL SUPPORTIVE.
OF THE COMPANION BILL WHICH WAS
S. B. WON ALL.
THREE PUT IN THERE TH IT TOOK
OF THE MONEY WOULD GO TO LOCAL
SMALL BUSINESSES [INAUDIBLE]
OWNERS [INAUDIBLE]
UP.
WE NEED DEFINITION OF LOCAL.
DOES THAT MEAN --
THAT BE YOU KNOW IT'S THE COUNTY
DOESN'T MEAN THE CITY DOESN'T
MEAN US HOPEFULLY IT MEANS A
STATE.
BUT ONE OF OUR AND ACTUALLY IT'S
THE CHAIR OF OUR ORGANIZATION --
HAS A STRIPING COMPANY.
AND SHE BID ON BOWED.
OUT OF FIVE CONTRACTS YOU CAN
ONLY BEEN ON TO BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T BUNDLE ON AND THE TWO
WENT TO OREGON FIRMS THIS
CONCERNS US.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT
AND REEVALUATE --
THE INCENTIVE FOR SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS TO WHAT TO DO --
GOVERNOR A STATE CONTRACTING IN
IN THAT DIRECTION [INAUDIBLE]
UP.
THE OTHER AREA THAT WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS MINIMUM WAGE
AND WE HAVE TO AMENDMENTS WE'D
LIKE TO OFFER.
WE AT FIRST WE WOULD LIKE TO
OFFER A STUDENT EXEMPTION FOR
STUDENTS THAT ARE --
ENROLLED IN SCHOOL AND THEY
WOULD HAVE TO SHOW THAT AND
SECONDLY TOTAL COMPENSATION.
THIS IS MORE THAN THE TIP CREDIT
IT INCLUDES ALL SMALL FARMERS.
THAT FURNISH HOUSING AS PART OF
THE SALARY.
IT ALSO INCLUDES PEOPLE LIKE MY
BUSINESS THAT IF YOU'RE A GOOD
SALES PERSON.
YOU TAKE LOVE IT DIDN'T BLOW
BASS HIGHER COMMISSION.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
PENALIZED BECAUSE IF YOU'RE
MEDIOCRE YOU TAKE A HIGHER BASE
ANALYZE A LOWER COMMISSION.
SO WE NEED MAYBE A LITTLE MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN THAT AREA.
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY OF BEING
THE UMBRELLA ADVOCACY GROUP
FIRST SEE EIGHT SMALL BUSINESS
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND WE PARTNER WITH WITH MANY
OTHER.
OF ONE OF OUR NEWEST ISSUES AND
PROJECTS.
IS ON THE HOMELESS.
HOMELESSNESS AND LET ME TELL YOU
A STORY FROM CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
HAIRED HAIR SALON.
SAID SHE IS LOST HALF OF HER
CLIENTELE.
BECAUSE OF THE HOMELESS WEAKENED
IN THE DOORWAY TO AND SHE IS IN
A SHOPPING CENTER.
AND THE SLAVE IN THE DOORWAY AND
OF THE WOMEN ARE AFRAID TO COME
INTO HER HAIR SALON.
SO WE NEED TO WORK TO HELP THEM.
BUT WE NEED TO WORK TO SOLVE
THAT AND WE ARE ALL --
READY AND WILLING AND ABLE TO
WORK ON THAT.
SO WHAT COULD YOU DO TO HELP US.
WELL I THINK SMALL BUSINESS AND
I'M GOING TO DIFFERENTIATE
BETWEEN ENTREPRENEURS SMALL
BUSINESS.
SMALL BUSINESSES TO ME HAVE
EMPLOYEES [INAUDIBLE]
AND WE NEED ED --
EXPRESSION THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND I THINK MOST OF IT IS
UNINTENTIONAL.
WHEN SOMETHING NEGATIVE HAPPENS
TO THE SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY
I DON'T THINK THE INTENT WAS TO
HURT THE COMMUNITY?
BUT THERE ARE SEVERAL THINGS
THAT WE COULD DO TO HAVE AN
EXPRESSION OF GOVERNMENT GETS IT.
GOVERNMENT WANTS TO HELP.
AND GOVERNMENT IS LISTENING --
I THINK IT'S TIME TO REVISIT THE
FIVE FOUR DAY TEN HOUR WEEK IF
FOR NO OTHER REASON BECAUSE OF
TRANSPORTATION.
TRAFFIC AND THE FACT THAT
EMPLOYEES OR HAVING TO DRIVE SO
FAR.
IT WOULD IT BE EASIER TO DRIVE
FOUR DAYS THEN IT WOULD BE FIVE
DAYS -- THE
THING YOU ALSO WORKED ON IS
RIGHT TO CURE I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE YOU CONTINUE ON THAT --
THE MOST OTHER THINGS SIX SMALL
BUSINESS US WRONG WHEN THEY'RE
AUDITED.
IF THEY WERE GIVEN A CHANCE TO
CURE IT YOU'D NEVER SEE AGAIN
BUT BOY TROLL THE BOOKS ADAM IF
THEY DON'T CORRECTED AND AND DO
IT CORRECTLY IN THAT AREA
[INAUDIBLE]
ALL.
I THINK WE NEED.
TO SEND A MESSAGE.
FROM SACRAMENTO TO THE SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY STATEWIDE.
THAT YOU CARE.
AND I KNOW YOU DO --
BECAUSE NINETY TWO OUT OF A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY LEGISLATORS
DO CONTACT REGULARLY WITH A
SMALL BUSINESS ADVISORY COUNCIL.
UP WITH THEIR COMMUNITY AND THIS
LIAISON IS REALLY IMPORTANT
THERE'S NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT
THAN YOUR CONSTITUENTS TALKING
TO YOU S. AS WE'RE DOING TODAY.
SO THANK YOU FOR ALL YOU DO HELP
US SEND A MESSAGE CALIFORNIA
CARES ABOUT SMALL BUSINESS --
WE'RE KIND OF DEPRESSED IT
CALIFORNIA'S SMALL BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION BECAUSE TWO OF OUR
BOARD MEMBERS.
HAVE DECIDED TO MOVE OUT OF
STATE AND THAT'S A SIGN THAT WE
DON'T LIKE AND WE'VE GOT TO
CORRECT AND WE WANT TO WORK WITH
YOU TO MAKE IT HAS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANKS
TO THE WORK YOU DO AND I'M GLAD
YOU BROUGHT UP THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY BECAUSE THAT IS A HUGE
ISSUE [INAUDIBLE]
HAS.
TAKE A WHOLE LOT TO IT BEYOND
WORKERS COMP ALTHOUGH THAT
CERTAINLY APART --
MY HUSBAND IS A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER IS A LANDSCAPE DESIGNER
AND CONTRACTOR.
AND ON IT EVERY DAY HE IS I HAS
BIDS AT A REJECTED FROM
HOMEOWNERS BECAUSE HE KNOWS THAT
THEY ARE TAKING BITS FROM --
CONTRACTORS WHO WERE IN.
POINT PEOPLE TO THE UNDERGROUND
ECONOMY PAYING THEIR EMPLOYEES
CASH UNDER THE TABLE NOT PAYING
TAXES ON THEM NOT PAYING WORKERS
COMP.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT IT ABSOLUTELY
PENALIZES THE GOOD OPERATORS AND
PUTS THOSE HOMEOWNERS IN A LOT
OF FINANCIAL JEOPARDY IF
SOMETHING SHOULD HAPPEN TO GO
WRONG ON THEIR PROPERTY.
I TO EMPLOYEE IS NOT COVERED.
I'M BY THEIR EMPLOYER SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT UP.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THIS
COMMITTEE [INAUDIBLE]
SUPPLY.
NEXT WE HOUSEHOLD WANNA A TOLEDO
FOUNDER AND CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OFFICER FOR
COLLABORATIVE PLAY.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
MONNING ASSEMBLYMEMBERS SORRY MY
VOICE IT'S I'VE BEEN A LITTLE
BIT SICK.
ISAAC BEACON HEAR ME OKAY --
WELL --
CLOUD PLAY OPEN EIGHT STORES AND
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN OCTOBER OR
NOVEMBER.
I IT'S A COWORKING SPACE THAT
OFFERS ON SITE CHILDCARE --
THEY PURPOSE OF THESE BUSINESS
HAS PAIN TO HELP.
I'M WE MEN --
ENTER THE WORKFORCE AFTER HAVING
A BABY.
I SCENES THERE'S LARGE
PERCENTAGE OF WOMEN --
OF RAMPING CORPORATE JOBS I ONCE
THEY HAVE A CHILD.
POUNDS GIVEN THE FACT THAT I
NOTABLY CORPORATIONS.
DO NOT OFFER --
FIXABLE --
OUR WHICH IS HIGHLY NEEDED WHEN
THEY HAVE.
I'M SO I OPEN THIS BUSINESS
BECAUSE I WAS THAT MOM
INCORPORATION --
AND I DID END UP HAVING TO COME
TO A DECISION OF QUITTING --
MY JOB. TWO BECAUSE THE HOURS
THAT I WAS EXPECTED --
TO PROVIDE AYE MY WORKSPACE --
THE TO BENEFIT MONTHLY LIFESTYLE
THAT I WANTED TO PROVIDE.
ON TO MY CHILD [INAUDIBLE]
I'M.
SO YOU OPEN THE DOORS TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND I AM.
SAT TO SAY WE ARE SHUTTING DOWN
ID AND A FEW SMALL --
EIGHTS AIR.
AYE IT'S GONNA BE HARD NOT TO
SHED A TEAR HERE --
WE I'M I'M HAPPY TO SAY THOUGH
THAT SORT OF THE CITY YEARS WE
HAVE BEEN IMPACTING THE LIVES.
OF MANY MOTHERS AND ON FATHERS --
WE'VE OPENED OUR DOORS --
NOT TO SORT OF JUST WOMEN BY WE
HAVE HELPED OUT A LOT OF FREE
DOWNS BARONS FIGHTERS CREATIVES.
BUSINESS OWNERS --
AND WE HAVE SEEN THE OREGON
COLLABORATION THAT HAS
FLOURISHED FROM THESE SPACE SO
WE BUILT A COMMUNITY.
NOT ONLY JUST THE QUIRKY SPACE --
WE HELPED CHRISTINE --
KIDS --
LEARN.
TO WALK CRAWL WALK AND TALK --
IS SO AND WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE.
ON WELL WE KNOW THAT THAT'S IN
THEIR ENTIRETY NEXT IT'S SO.
BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT WOULD.
MICHAEL WHEN IT FIRST OPENED
LAST TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE
CHILDCARE HOME [INAUDIBLE]
AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE.
AND IN A FLEXIBLE WORK
ENVIRONMENT [INAUDIBLE]
M..
SO.
I GUESS WHAT I AM I AM I WOULD
LOVE TO SHARE TO THEY I MEAN
STUFF.
DIFFERENT CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES --
BUT I'M THE MAIN THE MAIN ASPECT --
HASBEEN THEIR RENT --
I WHERE I WHERE RENT IT'S VERY
VERY HIGH --
ASSIST US IN YOU'LL BE SO.
YOU'RE SICK GO AIR I STARTED
WITH THE BROWN YOU CONCEPT I WAS
THE FIRST GORKY SPACE WHICH
CHILD CARE --
TO ALBANY SOURCING IN ASSIGNED
JEALOUS --
AREA.
AND I SAID BROWN YOU CONCEPT
THERE'S A LOT OF LEARNING.
THAT YOU DO AND OBVIOUSLY ABOUT
A YEAR LESS THAN A YEAR AND TO
MY BUSINESS I KNEW THAT.
THIS SPACE I HAVE RENTED WAS
SENT --
GOING TO EVER HELP ME BECOME
PROFITABLE --
BECAUSE SO THEY LAY OUT AND THE
RENT -- I
LEARNED THAT TOO LATE OUT ONCE I
YELLED DAN ON A THREE YEAR LEASE.
A EITHER VERY HIGH.
RENTAL.
SO.
I A DEPLETED ALL MY SAVINGS
THROUGH ALL THESE THREE YEARS --
I DID I WAS NOT ABLE TO GET A A
A JOB BECAUSE I WAS RUNNING MY
BUSINESS SO --
A I'M BASICALLY SEEN THE WAY
THEY HERE THAT --
WITHIN ON OUR SO --
THE THAT WHAT I WOULD LOVE TO
SEE HAPPEN AND IT'S ON ONE AND
TAKE -- ONE
OF OUR BUT IF I MENTIONED
EARLIER AFFORDABLE RENT IT'S A
KEY SHOW --
BUT ALSO MAYBE FLEXIBLE TERMS
FOR THOSE THAT ARE STARTING A
NEW BUSINESS.
ESPECIALLY THE ONES THAT ARE
STARTING A NEW CONCEPT --
A IT MIGHT BE SEEN AS WELL
SUPPORT OF CONCEPT AND IT WAS
SUCCESSFUL.
BECAUSE IN THE CONCEPT ASPECT
MEANING I COULD.
THAT YOU COULD HAVE A IT WORK
ENVIRONMENT ON A CHILD CARE
ENVIRONMENT UNDER THE SAME ROOF --
BUT FINANCIALLY SPEAKING EIGHT
DIDN'T PROVE SUCCESSFUL.
I SAW A WE SAY HAD HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET OUT OF THE
LEASE --
I'VE I'VE TRY MULTIPLE TIMES
WITH THE LINE OR TO NEGOTIATE AN
EXIT AND THAT WAS NOT POSSIBLE.
SO ON I THINK IT WOULD BE
EXTREMELY BENEFICIAL --
WHETHER IS FROM --
EXISTING BROKER SKYLINE HORSE
EVEN IF THERE IS A CD OWN
PROPERTY THAT YOU KNOW WE COULD
HAVE ON SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
COULD HAVE ACCESS. TO ONE
AFFORDABLE RENT INTO FLEXIBLE
TERMS SO THAT WE COULD QUICKLY
I'M BOUGHT OUR BUSINESS WHEN --
WHEN WE REALIZED THAT WHAT WE
DID -- IT
WASN'T THE BEST.
THE C. SHOWN AND ANYTHING THAT'S
A VERY COMMON MISTAKE MORE --
YOU KNOW I I HAVE.
A CURRENTLY LOOKING AT MY BODY
MY BUSINESS SO I'M I'M SHUTTING
DOWN THE BRICK AND MORTAR.
I IN THE VOTING NEED TO HAVE
MORE OF OUR CONSULTING AND
MOBILE CHILDCARE.
OBSCENITIES THROUGH THE THREE
YEARS WE HAVE GROWN AT THAT THEY
ARE ON A LOT OF ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE THINKING A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT HUDDLE --
HOW TO VOTE BUSINESS IN A WAY
THAT IT'S TRULY INCLUSIVE?
AND IN ORDER TO BE TRULY
INCLUSIVE YOU ARM I BELIEVE
WHICH YOU DO HAVE TO HAVE A
CHILD CARE.
BOMB CONVERSATION AS PART OF IT --
BUT I'M HOPE THAT I COULD.
OUT CONTINUE TO RUN THEIR
BUSINESS HOUSE WE HAVE PROVIDED
CHILDCARE.
FILM FESTIVALS --
FRANCIS THE UNITED ON STATE OF
WOMEN CONFERENCE RECENTLY WITH
PROVIDED CHILDCARE --
OVERNIGHT WILL RECEIVE OVER
THIRTY ARE BEQUESTS --
TO HELP TAKE CARE OF CHILDREN.
SO THAT MOTHERS COULD GO TO THE
PANELS PARTICIPATE.
I'M SAYING WITH THEIR OUTFIELD
FESTIVALS --
AS I HEARD THE OTHER SPEAKERS I
A WAS IGNITED TO HEAR ALL THE
DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THERE ARE OUT THERE.
I AND I WILL FULLY TAKE
ADVANTAGE --
MOWING ON I I DEFTLY NOTICE
OTHER CD'S I WOULD LOVE --
THE CITY OF GLENDALE --
TO AND TO HAVE SOME WELL SOME OF
THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT I SEE
WITH THE CITY OF GLENDALE WITH
THEM.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE WEBSITE AYE
AND TO HELP HIM THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH HAS --
I KNOW ON CHANEL SHINNY.
MAIENSCHEIN AN EXAMPLE EARLIER I
AND I'VE SEEN HOW THEIR CITY OF
LONG BEACH HAS --
APPLAUD ALL BUSINESS PORTAL THAT
IT'S VERY SIMPLE TO FOLLOW
THROUGH.
I SAID IN YOUR BUSINESS OWNER
AND I I CAN ATTEST TO THESE
BECAUSE I DO HAVE A LOT OF
MEMBERS OF MICHAEL WORKING SPACE
THAT --
START FROM SCRATCH AND DON'T
KNOW REALLY WHAT IS DARK AND
IT'S REALLY CONFUSING.
AND TIME CONSUMING AREN'T SO AYE
BUSINESS PRO LIKE FAIRS HE OF
LONG BEACH WILL BE REALLY
VALUABLE --
AND I KNOW THAT MAYBE A STATE
LEVEL THAT'S ALREADY SOMETHING
IN PLACE SCENE DOT IN --
CD LEVEL WHEN.
I REALLY REALLY HELPFUL --
SOME OTHER --
OPPORTUNITIES THAT I SEE I THAT.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE HAPPEN --
WOULD BE MORE --
OR STRONGER ACADEMIC SHIPS WITH
THE CD I'M WITH THE COLLEGE --
OF THE CITY OF GLENDALE AM
INTERNS HELP SMALL BUSINESSES
THROUGHOUT THEY THREE YEARS I I
HAVE --
REACH OUT A LITTLE --
TO THE CITY COLLEGE BUT I THINK.
AND YOU KNOW THERE WERE MAYBE
SOME INCENTIVES FOR SCHOOL
CREDITS OR THINGS LIKE DOT IT
WOULD BE VERY BENEFICIAL --
OTHER WAYS ALSO BEYOND MAYBE
TRYING TO FIND OUT SOME CDS TO
PROVIDE.
AND EVEN THE SMALL LEVEL GRANTS
OUT JUST TO HELP THOSE IN JAPAN
HOURS START THEIR BUSINESSES SO
THEY CAN.
PERFORM THEIR GOAL COMPANIES --
IT WILL BE NO FROM A CORPORATE
INFORMATION.
ANYBODY WILL NEED A COUPLE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO GET STARTED
AND ADULT SWEETHEART WHEN --
WHEN YOU KNOW HOW THE FUNDS
[INAUDIBLE]
AND AND I HAVE TAX INCENTIVES --
I'VE I LOOKED UP ONE OF THE YORK --
THEY HAVE A PROGRAM CALLED START
UP YORK --
AND IT SAYS STOP I'M THE STATE
OF NEW YORK HELPS NEW AND
EXPANDABILITY SAYS.
THROUGH TAX BASE INCENTIVES AND
INNOVATIVE ACADEMIC PARTNERSHIPS
STATE OF NEW YORK OFFERS NEW AND
EXPANDED BE SAYS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OPERATE TAX FREE
FOR TEN YEARS.
ON OR NEAR ELIGIBLE UNIVERSITIES
ARE COLLEGE CAMPUSES IN YOUR
STATE.
PARTNERING WITH THE SCHOOLS
GIVES BUSINESSES DIRECT ACCESS
TO ADVANCED RESEARCH
LABORATORIES DEVELOPMENT
RESOURCES AND EXPERTS IN KEY
INDUSTRIES --
SO GIVEN THE FACT THAT --
KNOW THIS YOU HAVE GLENDALE IS
ALSO LOOKING.
TO REALLY ENERGIZE THE
TECHNOLOGY ECO SYSTEM HAVING
SOME SORT OF TAX INCENTIVE FOR
THOSE ENTREPRENEURS --
DIED ARE INTO TEXT BASED GAME
SOMETHING LIKE ALONG THOSE LINES
WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL.
THANK YOU SALON I'M VERY SAD
BECAUSE SORRY TO HEAR ABOUT YOUR
BUSINESS CLOSING I REMEMBER
VISITING YOU WHEN YOU FIRST OPEN
AND THINK [INAUDIBLE]
AN AMAZING. FOR THINKING CONCEPT
I IN FACT THERE'S A BILL RIGHT
NOW IN THE ASSEMBLY.
BELIEVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RANDY
VOEPEL. TO REQUIRE --
STATE OFFICES TO ALLOW --
NEW PARENTS TO BRING THEIR
CHILDREN TO WORK WITHOUT.
SO I THINK YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT
AHEAD OF YOUR TIME --
THAT I AM SORRY TO HEAR ABOUT
THE CLOSING AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMING TO SHARE
YOUR EXPERIENCES WITH EVERYBODY
THINK YOU.
AND ALSO THAT SOMETIMES WHEN WE
BEGIN SOMETHING WE GIVE IT OUR
ALL.
BUT WE DON'T QUITE MAKE IT AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN SAID
SOMETIMES WERE AHEAD OF OUR TIME
BUT WITHOUT A DOUBT YOUR
EXPERIENCE MAKES YOU.
THAT MUCH MORE OF AN EXPERT TO
HELP SOMEBODY ELSE YOU YOU THEN
BECOME AN ADVOCATE.
WHEN SOMEBODY ELSE NEEDS HELP IN
THE THINKING OF THE BUSINESS YOU
CAN TELL ABOUT YOUR EXPERIENCE?
AND WHAT YOU WOULD HAVE CHANGED
WHAT YOU WOULD HAVE DONE
DIFFERENTLY TO HELP THEM SUCCEED
IN THEIR BUSINESS AND CLEARLY
YOU'RE YOU'RE SOMEONE THAT IT
THAT IT APPEARS THAT.
IS WILLING TO HELP OTHERS IN MAY
HELP.
SEE BUT I I I WISH YOU GREAT
SUCCESS IN YOUR NEXT ENDEAVOR
THINK DON'T GIVE UP ON SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
WHATEVER THE TITLE IS RIGHT.
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO COLLEGE THANK YOU THANK YOU --
OUR LAST --
SPEAKER BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT IT'S TODD SCHWARTZ WHO'S
THE OWNER OF DICKEY'S BARBECUE
PIT WHICH IS A FAMOUS
[INAUDIBLE]
LOCAL RESTAURANT ACTUALLY IT'S
NOT DID.
IT IS PART OF A FRANCHISE SYSTEM
ALL I'M SORRY THERE ARE IT IS
THE LARGEST BARBECUE.
BOB WITH THE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
LOCATIONS RIGHT NOW AND I
THOUGHT THAT WE WERE UNIQUE YOU
WITH HOURS.
DO WHAT WE CAN --
BOTH MAKE IT FEEL LOCAL AND AND
ONE OF THE KEY POINTS I WANTED
TO TO BRING UP THIS OFTENTIMES
FRANCHISE OWNERS NOT CONSIDERED
LOCAL SMALL BUSINESS MEMBERS --
AND IN FACT GET EXCLUDED FROM
PROGRAMS LIKE SMALL BUSINESS
SATURDAY.
WELL.
IT'S MY MONEY IT YOU KNOW IT'S
MY FAMILY'S MONEY THAT'S IN THAT --
RESTAURANT --
IT'S THE SAME STAFF BUT GETS
PAID IT OUT OF YOU KNOW THE THE
SALES THAT WE HAVE --
AND EVERYTHING WE THAT GOES INTO
THE RESTAURANT COMES OUT OF THE
RESTAURANT.
IS PRODUCED BY THE BUSINESS
OWNER -- AND
YOU KNOW WE JUST GOT SOME
MARKETING SUPPORT AND AND PAY
ADDITIONAL MONEY. TO THE
FRANCHISE SYSTEM --
SO WE ARE VERY MUCH SMALL
BUSINESSES NEARLY --
AND AS SUCH UM WE JUST
CELEBRATED OUR SIXTH YEAR
MONSANTO'S --
ON JULY --
TWENTY SIX WE OPEN IN. TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE FOR A RESTAURANT
TO SURVIVE AS WE KNOW IS THAT IT
DIFFICULT. TO IMMEDIATELY AFTER
WE OPENED WE HAD NO.
CLUE THAT --
WHICH IS REALLY GOING UP AT AN
INCREDIBLE RATE --
HEALTH DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
RAISING FEES ON EVERYTHING WE'VE
WE OFFER A FREE SOFT SERVE
[INAUDIBLE]
THE CUSTOMERS I WAS ONE OF OUR
STAPLES --
WHICH MAKES ME A SOFT SERVE --
MANUFACTURERS LIKE A SAUCER
MANUFACTURER BERMAN --
WHICH HAS GONE UP FROM HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY FIVE TO THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS. TO
THE COUNTY OUT WHILE THE SERVICE
WHICH USED TO BE RUN SEPARATELY
FROM MORE TO HEALTH FOOD UP
ASSEMBLY SPECTER NOW AFFORDABLE
SOMETHING THE SAME INSPECTOR AND
DOES THAT HOUSE.
SO THEY'RE USING HER PEOPLE THE
CHARGING A LOT MORE OUT OF THE
COUNTY ALSO JUST RAISED I THINK
[INAUDIBLE] 30%.
A 15% INCREASE ON OUR ARE
RESURRECTED WE KNOW IT.
ON OUR BOARD OF HEALTH FOR ME.
SO I JUST PAID TWELVE HUNDRED
AND I'LL GET A BILL FOR ANOTHER.
NOT THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS --
THOSE ARE PERMITS PLEASE PERMITS
SO IF YOU'RE WONDERING HOW.
WHERE THE COST THOSE ARE ALL
LOCAL BECAUSE --
THE SO.
YOU I'M WITH ONE MY MY FAVORITE
THINGS ABOUT BEING A BUSINESS
OWNER IS.
I GET AND WERE LOCATED NEAR CAL
STATE NORTHRIDGE.
SO WE HIRED A LOT OF STUDENTS WE
HIRED YOU KNOW WHILE THEY'RE IN
SCHOOL WE OFFER FLEXIBLE
SCHEDULING.
SO THAT WHEN THEY HAVE CLASSES
WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO KNOW TO
WORK AROUND THEIR SCHEDULE AND
HAVING STOP THAT WE CAN FILL IN
THE HOLES --
I KNOW THERE'S A BILL OUT THERE
COMES AND GOES SEEMS FOR PAST
YEARS FOR PREDICTIVE SCHEDULING --
PREDICTIVE SCHEDULING WOULD BE
DEVASTATING TO US --
I OFFER A THREE WEEK SCHEDULE
CURRENTLY.
BUT NINE TIMES OUT OF TEN THE
STAFF CHANGES THE SCHEDULE --
YOU KNOW THEY NEED PEOPLE TO
COVER THEIR SHIPS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE OTHER THINGS THAT COME UP.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING
THREE WEEKS FROM TODAY TWO
O'CLOCK THAT NIGHT.
I THOUGHT YOU HAD TO BE THERE SO
THAT HAS RULING IMPACT.
AND I KNOW THAT THERE ARE
PROVISIONS IN SOME OF THESE
PREDICTIVE SCHEDULING BILLS. TO
ALLOW SOMEBODY SAID TO GET THE
HIRE SOMEBODY AND THEN THERE'S
NO PENALTIES.
HIRE SOMEBODY FROM BRING
SOMEBODY FROM ANOTHER SHIFT
EVERYTHING NOW HOW SOMEBODY ELSE
THAT I HAVE TO FILL THAT SHIFT
VOCAL BACK PERSON FROM.
SO KIND OF ROLLS DOWNHILL --
SO JUST KEEP IN MIND THE PURSUIT
OF SCHEDULING FOR RESTAURANT.
IS IS PRETTY DEADLY --
IN ADDITION BIGGER RESTAURANT WE
OFFER CATERING SERVICES
[INAUDIBLE]
AND PEOPLE DON'T PLAN AHEAD I
GOT A CALL LAST NIGHT. FOR FIFTY
PEOPLE WANT THE CATERING ON
SATURDAY.
I HAVE STAFF THAT IS GLAD TO DO
IT THEY WANT THE EXTRA HOURS SO
THEY CAN COME IN.
BUT UNDER THESE PREDICTIVE
SCHEDULING BILLS I HAVE TO PAY A
PENALTY. FOR GIVING MY STAFF
ADDITIONAL HOURS.
SO THEN I HAVE TO WAYS OF WORTH
TAKING IS A CATERING OR NOT TAKE
CARE -- MOST
THE TIME A CATERING SCUM AND
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
SO YOU DON'T HAVE AN OFFICE
LUNCH THAT WAS IMPLANTED OR YOU
KNOW I'M ALWAYS AMAZED WHEN.
SOMEBODY TELLS IT'S EITHER GOT
FORTY PEOPLE FOR DINNER TOMORROW
NIGHT MIGHT REALLY ALL OF THE
SUDDEN.
YOU OFFER DIFFERENT --
BUT WE CAN DO IT BOTH WILL DO IT --
SO PREDICT THE SCHEDULING NUMBER
ONE ON THE LIST.
ARE THERE SOME UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES THAT SHOW UP
FREQUENTLY --
SICK PAY.
THE BILL IS NOW SIX DAYS OUR
SHIPS BY THE WAY ARE.
GENERALLY SIX HOURS BY THE HAVE
TO SIX HOURS --
AND SICK PAY WORKS ON A TWENTY
FOUR HOUR DAY.
SO INSTEAD OF GETTING.
IF IT'S A THREE DAY INSTEAD OF
GETTING THREE DAYS OF SICK HEADS
ACTUALLY TWENTY FOUR HOURS WOULD
BE FIVE DAYS OF SICK PAY.
THEY FIVE SERVICE WHEN IT GOES
TO SIX THAT'S TEN DAYS.
OF SICK PAY HEARING CITY ABOUT
WHY --
BECAUSE THE CASE IS A NO
QUESTIONS ASKED POLICY THERE'S
NO DOCTORS NO THERE NOTHING
REQUIRED TO SAY YOU WERE SAYING --
BECAUSE WE HAVE STUDENTS.
SATURDAY NIGHT IN THE SUMMER
FRIDAY NIGHTS IN THE SUMMER
STUDENTS MAKE OTHER PLANS.
SO THEY CALL IN SICK.
AND THEY DON'T GIVE YOU NOTICE.
YOU KNOW WE ASK.
BUT THEY FEAR THAT IF WE GIVE US
NOTICE THEM IS NOT CONSIDERED A
SICK DAY.
SO LOW COST THAT AFTERNOON EXACT
INCOME AND OR THOUGH BECAUSE OF
THE START OF THEIR SHIFT AND SAY
HEY I NEED TO SIT BACK --
GOING TO CONCERTS.
YOU KNOW AND SO WE HAVE THIS
TIME BECAUSE THEY GET PAID
ANYWAY.
THERE'S NO INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO
SHOW UP ON THOSE WEEKENDS DURING
THE SUMMER [INAUDIBLE]
REALLY.
A REAL ISSUE --
AND IT'S NOT JUST ONE BUT I FEEL
I KNOW MANY RESTAURANTS ARE
FEELING.
AROUND THIS FACILITY --
SAID SOMETHING TO KEEP IN MIND I
I WAS AT THE HEARINGS PERCENT
PAY I KNOW THE ISSUES THAT COME
UP WITH FAMILIES OF SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW TRYING TO BE AS
FLEXIBLE AS POSSIBLE BUT WHEN WE
DO A BLANKET [INAUDIBLE]
LAW.
THAT DOESN'T TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE SITUATION.
AT ALL IT'S NO QUESTIONS ASKED
ITS WHATEVER YOU CAN GET AROUND
TO CALLING.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO CALL IT THE
DAY AFTER THE START OF HER SHIFT.
ANY OF THOSE FACTORS.
TOTALLY.
I'M FINE UNDER THE OCCURRENCE OF
PEBBLES --
IN ADDITION [INAUDIBLE]
THE THE WAGE INCREASES --
ARE BIG UNKNOWN FOR US.
THERE WERE RESTAURANTS.
THE STAFF GETS TAPPED OUT OF A
CERTAIN UPS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT A
FULL SERVICE WHICH GOING FROM WE
JUST WANT TO TWELVE DOLLARS
RAISE PRICES.
WE GOT A FIFTEEN DOLLARS UNITS
ANOTHER BIG INCREASED FROM
THIRTEEN TWENTY FIVE AND FIFTEEN
AND THEN IT'S GONNA BE TIED TO
INFLATION.
WHICH MEANS WE'RE GONNA HAVE
WAGE INCREASES EVERY YEAR.
BECAUSE EVERY TIME WE RAISE
WAGES BUSINESSES HAVE TO RAISE
PRICES.
SO WE'VE CREATED A SPIRAL.
THAT.
IS GONNA MAKE IT VERY HARD FOR
US TO STABILIZE WAGES IN
PREDICTING THE FUTURE.
WHAT OUR WAGES ARE SO WHAT A
RESTAURANTS DOING WHAT WE CALL
CUTS DOWN?
I HAD SIXTEEN PEOPLE WHEN I
OPENED.
WHICH IS WHEN EVERYONE TO
FOURTEEN AND I DON'T.
TWELVE AND FOR AWHILE WE WERE
ATTACKED --
ONCE.
EVERYBODY GOES BACK TO SCHOOL
WILL BE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TEN
AND TWELVE PEOPLE --
FROM WHAT I'M SEEING IN OTHER
CITIES THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING
ACROSS RAIMES.
WE'VE GOT TO STOP.
SO IT'S NOT THAT YOU KNOW OR WE
CUT THE HOURS.
THAT THE STAFF IS WORKING FINE
FROM SEVEN HOUR SHIFTS TO SIX
HOURS OF SURVIVORSHIP --
SO IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT KEEP IN
MIND REFUSE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES ARE BECAUSE WE
STILL HAVE TO MEET THAT BOTTOM
LINE IS NOT THAT WE WANT TO GET
FROM LOS.
STOCK TO MEET THE BOTTOM.
ONE IT IT'S REALLY ABOUT HOW
MUCH ARE YOU WILLING TO PAY FOR
YOUR MEAL.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A POINT THAT
WE'RE GONNA BE PRICING.
CUSTOMERS OUT OF THE RESTAURANT --
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO COVER SO MUCH
IN WAGES.
AS I JUST WAGES ITS WORKERS COMP
AND IT'S WITH TAXES ON WHICH
BRINGS ME MY NEXT POINT --
AND BETTY WAS KIND ENOUGH TO
BRING IT UP.
WE DON'T HAVE A TOTAL
COMPENSATION PLAN HERE IN THE
STATE.
I KNOW THE RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN ADVOCATING --
FOR ONE BUT ONE OF THE FIRST
STEPS I THINK IS.
WHEN A CUSTOMER LEAVES THE TEST?
FOR SOMEBODY WHO WORKS AT THE
RESTAURANT.
I HAVE TO PAY TAX.
ON A PORTION OF THAT.
TO THE EMPLOYER PAYS TAX ON IT
UP AS WELL WHICH IS TOTALLY FINE
WITH THEIR INCOME [INAUDIBLE]
BUT I HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF AN
ISSUE THAT.
THE TIP IS COUNTED AS WAGES WHEN
I HAVE TO PAY TAXES OF THE STATE.
AND WORKERS COMP BECAUSE IT'S
ABOUT BASIS WELL.
BUT IS NOT COUNTED AS WAGES
TOWARDS MINIMUM WAGE.
SO SOMETIMES IT'S CONSIDERED A
WAGE SOMETIMES IT'S NOT
CONSIDERED A WAGE AND IT SEEMS
TO BE WHENEVER IT'S CONVENIENT.
TO MAXIMIZE THE AMOUNT OF THE
BUSINESS HAS TO PAY.
SO MY FIRST TASK.
IS PERHAPS WE CAN WAIVE THE
EMPLOYER PORTION.
OF THE TAX ON TIPS.
IT DOES SEEM FAIR ABOUT.
LIKE ABOUT 1212%.
ON EVERY DOLLAR.
THAT EMPLOYEE MAKES ATTEMPTS.
WHICH I CAN STEP --
THE LAST THING.
AND AGAIN I I CAN'T SUPPORT
READY ENOUGH THAT HER RIGHT TO
TERRACE STATEMENTS.
YOU KNOW.
THE THE CALIFORNIA'S THIS IS
VERY COMPLICATED.
AND GIVING THEM A BUSINESS OWNER
THE RIGHT TO CARE ONE ERROR
SERVERS ARE.
FAMOUSLY --
IS.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT I
THINK 90% OF THE TIME DEFINED
BUSINESS DO IT IF THEY DON'T DO
IT.
BENNY COME DOWN HARD ON A THE
NEW.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TAXATION WEBSITE.
IS VERY CONFUSING.
MUCH MORE COMPLICATED THAN THE
OLD BOARD OF EQUALIZATION
WEBSITE.
AND I'D HOPE THAT SOMEBODY TAKES
A LOOK AT IT AND SIMPLIFIES A
FOR BUSINESS OWNERS.
IS TRYING TO FIND WHERE TO PAY
THE TAXES [INAUDIBLE]
IT'S DIFFICULT --
AND IT APPEARS THAT THEY'RE
TAKING LONGER TO PROCESS THE
PAYMENT [INAUDIBLE]
AS WELL --
SO.
I WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT'S
GOING ON THERE --
AND THAT'S YOU KNOW ESSENTIALLY
BE UP THE OTHER PART THAT WE'RE
FACING WHICH I WILL BRING UP.
IS I HAS A RESTAURANT WE ARE NOW
USING LOTS OF THIRD PARTY
DELIVERY SO.
GRUBHUB DOOR DAKSH POSE MEANS.
TWENTY FOUR NINA GLOBAL TRYING
USE THEM ALL --
THEY'LL TAKE A PERCENTAGE OF OUR
SALES.
COMMISSION WHICH WE HAPPILY PAY
BECAUSE THEY COVER THE COST OF
THE DELIVERY.
CURRENTLY THEY COLLECT THE SALES
TAX.
ON THE SALE.
OF THE TOTAL AMOUNT SOLD.
BUT THEY DON'T PAY SALES TAX
THEY PASSED BUT SALES TAX BACK
TO THE RESTAURANT.
AND THEN WE HAVE TO PAY SALES
TAX ON WHAT THEY SENT TO US OFF
ON WHAT OUR SAILORS WHICH IS
ACTUALLY NOT WHAT THEY SEEM TO
US.
BECAUSE I'VE TAKEN A COMMISSION
OFF OF THAT.
IT'S BECOMING MORE MORE
COMPLICATED TO TRAFFIC AS WE ALL
USE REVENUE.
FROM SO MANY DIFFERENT DELIVERY
SYSTEMS AS TO WHAT PORTION THAT
THEY'RE SENDING US A SALES WHICH
PART IS SALES TAX --
AND THERE WHICH ARE WE ABOUT TO
STATE.
AND I THINK WE LOOK AT IT AND
HAD THE THIRD PARTY SERVICES.
PAVE SALES TAX THAT THEY COLLECT
ON THE STATE WOULD PROBABLY DO
BETTER.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE MORE CHANCE OF
GETTING THAT SALES TAX. TO THE
CORRECT AMOUNT --
AND WOULD BE SOMETHING A LITTLE
EASIER FOR THE RESTAURANTS HAVE
TO ATTRACT.
THANK YOU BADLY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU IT WAS --
IT WAS VERY VERY HELPFUL AND
CERTAINLY A LOT OF ISSUES THAT
ARE PARTICULAR TO RESTAURANTS
BUT THEY'RE HUGE.
SECTION OF OUR SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY SO IT'S NO REALLY GOOD
TO HE SECURITY AND ALSO THERE
ARE A LOT OF ISSUES THAT ARE
COMMON TO A LOT OF DIFFERENT
BUSINESSES LIKE THE FLEXIBILITY
IN SCHEDULING.
A SIX STATE SICK DAY ISSUE WHICH
WE HEARD FROM A LOT OF
BUSINESSES UNANSWERED --
EXPERIENCE WELL WITH HIS
EMPLOYEES I DO HAVE A QUESTION
FOR YOU AND I AM ASKING THIS
HONESTLY NOT WITH ANY PREJUDICE --
WHY STILL GIVEN THAT YOUR
CUSTOMERS ARE THINKING ABOUT
WHAT THE TOTAL?
NEIL EXPERIENCES COSTING THEM.
AND GIVEN THAT YOU'RE NOW PAYING
A LIVING WAGE WHERE YOU ALLOWING
TIPPING.
WHY IS THAT STILL PART OF YOUR
BUSINESSES AND NON FULL SERVICE
RESTAURANT GIVEN THAT YOU'RE
PAYING TAX UNDER YOUR EMPLOYEES
ARE NO LONGER GETTING SUB
MINIMUM WAGES AS WAITERS THEY'RE
NOW GETTING?
A LIVING WAGE I AND THEN YOU
COULD THAT YOU CAN CONTROL AND
SUPPLEMENT IF YOU NEED TO I
THINK A LIVING WAGES AND NUMBER.
TWELVE DOLLARS AN HOUR OR IN THE
FOURTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR.
KNOWING OF RENTS ARE.
LIKE PEOPLE LIVING IN A SO WHAT
I FOUND INITIALLY WE DID NOT
ALLOW TIPPING AT ALL --
BY.
THE CITY OF LA SET UP TO WAGES.
AND RIGHT NOW BEING UNDER TWENTY
SIX EMPLOYEES MY MINIMUM WAGES.
TWELVE IF I HAD MORE THAN TWENTY
SIX EMPLOYER. THIRTEEN TWENTY
FIVE BUT AS AN EMPLOYER I HAVE
TO COMPETE FOR EMPLOYEES.
FROM BIGGER RESTAURANTS PREDICT
BUFFALO WILD WINGS ARE TGI
FRIDAY'S.
WHICH ALL HAVE OVER TWENTY SIX
TOYS SO THEY'RE PAYING THIRTEEN
TWENTY FIVE AN HOUR AS A BASE --
ALLOWING THE TIPPING GETS MY
EMPLOYEES UP. TO FOURTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE FIFTEEN DOLLARS
EVERY PAYCHECK --
AND IT ALLOWS ME TO RETAIN THOSE
EMPLOYEES --
IN THE PROCESS WHICH IS
[INAUDIBLE]
A VALUABLE --
BANG AND IT HELPS THEM IT MAKES
MORE MONEY FOR THE EMPLOYEES SO.
YOU KNOW I LOOK AT IT HAS --
A WIN FOR THE EMPLOYEES THAT TO
A LARGE PART AND REDUCES
TURNOVER [INAUDIBLE] FOR ME.
AND THERE SERVICES BETTER
KNOWING THAT THEY'RE TALKING TO
THE CUSTOMERS.
AND ENGAGING CUSTOMERS AS THEY
GO THROUGH OUR LINE --
SO THE CUSTOMER REALLY FEELS
LIKE THEY'RE PART OF THE PROCESS.
SO WE'RE WE'RE NOT A HOLDING
COMPANY WERE VERY WARM. TO THE
RESTAURANT AND OTHER ENGAGE WITH
YOU ABOUT HOW YOUR DAY IS.
WHAT KIND OF FOOD YOU WANT AN
OBVIOUS?
SO IT GIVES US A LITTLE HIGHER
LEVEL OF CUSTOMER SERVICE.
WHEN THEY KNOW THAT THEY CAN
BECOME HE STATED [INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
THREAT THAT SPOKE BEFORE YOU
WALK AWAY [INAUDIBLE]
YOU PROVIDED.
WHY LIST IT DOES HAVE SOME OF
THE OTHER SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
I REALLY THANK YOU FOR THAT --
I THINK A COMMENT OF SOMEONE
NUMBER FRIEDMAN MADE EARLIER IS
THAT.
THE LARGE CORPORATIONS HAVE
THEIR PAID LOBBYISTS THE COMING
IN AND WE HEAR FROM THEM
WHENEVER THERE'S ANY LEGISLATION
THAT'S GOING TO AFFECT THEM.
WE DO FOR IT AYE AYE ENGAGE MY
CHAMBERS I HAVE CHAMBERS IN
EVERY CITY SOME OF THE MORE ARE
MORE ENGAGING THAN OTHERS.
I ALSO HAVE A SMALL BUSINESS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT MEETS ON
A QUARTERLY BASIS.
IF LIKE IF WE DON'T HEAR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
THEN WE'RE NOT TOTALLY INFORMED
WHEN IT'S TIME FOR US TO VOTE ON
SOMETHING --
WEEK WE HEAR FROM THE EMPLOYEES.
ABOUT WHAT THEY NEED AND WHAT
THEY WANT.
HAVING THE INPUT FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT WE WANT TO HEAR FROM
YOU -- ONE
EXAMPLE THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT
WAS THE PREDICTIVE SCHEDULING
THAT WAS BROUGHT UP BY ONE OF
THE SPEAKERS BEFORE YOU.
WE KNOW WHY IT IS IMPORTANT.
AND WHY WE NEED TO HAVE IT.
WE ALSO NEED TO KNOW FROM THE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE MOST
AFFECTED BY IT AND PERHAPS SOME
OF THE EXCEPTIONS TO COMMUNICATE
TO ANY OF THE RULES OR ANY OF
THE THAT THE LAWS THAT WE THAT
WE THAT WE ENACT.
THAT WE'D THE BILLS THAT WE
INTRODUCE.
SO PLEASE SPEAK WITH US.
WHETHER IT'S WITH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN OR MY OFFICE WE WANT TO
HEAR FROM YOU AND SOMETIMES WE
CAN FIND WAYS. TWO OUT OF THE
EXCEPTION ANOTHER ONE THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP WAS THE RIGHT TO CURE.
I I HAD A NUMBER OF THOSE COME
TO MY COMMITTEE SOME OF THOSE WE
KNEW WE WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO VOTE.
FOR LIKE EIGHTY COMPLIANCE
THAT'S ALREADY THE LAW AND WE
HAVE TO KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO
COMPLY WITH ADA COMPLIANCE.
THERE WERE A FEW OTHERS WERE
PROVIDED.
THE OPPOSE THE WAS TO PROVIDE A
THIRTY DAY WINDOW.
CURED.
WE NEED TO LOOK AT ALL OF THOSE
EXAMPLES AND IT MAKES IT MUCH
EASIER WHEN WE'RE SPEAKING AND
COMMITTEE WHEN WE SAY.
WE HEARD FROM THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT OUR COMMUNITY
THIS IS HOW THEY ARE AFFECTED.
AS OPPOSED TO JUST HEARING
TESTIMONY FROM ONE SMALL
BUSINESS [INAUDIBLE]
THERE AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO BASE IT ON SO DO DO
REACH OUT TO US.
DO TELL US YOUR OPINIONS DOESN'T
ALWAYS GO ONE PERSON THERE ONE
GROUPS WHERE ANOTHER GROUP'S
WEIGHT BUT WE DO NEED TO HEAR
FROM YOU.
THAT'S WHY MY SMALL BUSINESS BY
SMALL BUSINESS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE.
THEY'RE CALLING AND SPEAKING
WITH DANIEL --
FROM MY OFFICE WHO IS OUR EXPERT
ON SMALL BUSINESSES AND
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
WE NEED TO HEAR FROM YOU AND WE
WELCOME YOUR YOUR COMMENTS SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I APPRECIATE THAT I
AND WHAT.
AT HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP THAT IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT FOR A LOT OF
SMALL BUSINESSES.
TIME AWAY FROM THEIR BUSINESS
EITHER GO TO SACRAMENTO OR OR
COME TO YOUR OFFICES --
ALCOHOL BACK AND THEN THEY DON'T
REALLY THINK ABOUT WAYS IS GOING
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE YOU KNOW I
I DO GO UP SACRAMENTO WHAT THE
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION --
AND WE APPRECIATE IT AND I KNOW
THE PROJECT IS GOING STARTED TO
SOMETHING IF YOU HAVE MORE THAN
FIVE HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AND IT'S
CONTINUED TO DWINDLE THAT THE
NUMBER KEEP SHRINKING.
SO KEEP IN MIND RESTAURANTS ON A
VERY DIFFERENT BUSINESS --
AND IF THERE'S GOING TO CARVE
OUT THAT THINK THAT WOULD BE
WELL WORTH PARTY AT THE
RESTAURANT BUSINESS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I DON'T HAVE ANY MORE SPEAKERS
ON THE AGENDA BUT WE'RE GOING TO
OPEN UP THE FLOOR TO PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
THERE'S ANYBODY HERE --
WHO WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS US I
WILL GIVE YOU ABOUT THREE
MINUTES EACH?
COME ON UP TO THE TO THE DYESS --
ONE BY.
ONE WELCOME THANK YOU FOR COMING.
I DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE THE TIMERS
THIS IS GOING TO BE IT'S IT'LL
BE VERY SURE IT'S OUT ALISON I
LOST FOR THIS LEDGER AND I'M
ALSO THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
LOS FELIS.
BUSINESS IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT I
HAVE LEARNED SO MUCH HERE TODAY
AND I AM SO GLAD I CAME WHEN I
STARTED MY BUSINESS FIFTEEN
YEARS AGO I HAD NO IDEA WHAT I
WAS DOING.
AND THEY MADE A LOT OF MISTAKES
TOO SO I'M I'M VERY HAPPY THAT I
STILL EXIST --
I JUST WANTED TO SAY IN LOS
FELIS IT'S ALL ABOUT --
THERE'S NO PLACE TO PARK --
WE RECENTLY BOUGHT A STORY IN
THE LEDGER WHERE AND A NUMBER OF
BUSINESSES CLOSE AND THE CITED.
THERE'S A PLACE TO PARK AND IT'S
A PROBLEM FOR THE BUSINESSES AND
FOR THE RESIDENTS BECAUSE YOU
WOULD A PARKING ON THEIR STREETS.
WE HAVE NO IDEA HOW TO SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM --
ALSO THE RENTS I THINK THAT
BETWEEN MY RUN FOR MY COMMERCIAL
OFFICE WELL AS MY RESIDENTS.
IS ABOUT SIXTY OR 70% OF MY
INCOME.
AND IT'S IT'S STAGGERING AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO SOLVE THAT
EITHER.
REGARDING THE BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICTS WHERE OF
LOS FELIS IS A VERY SMALL
BUSINESS IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT.
AND IT IS --
MERCHANT BASS BROTHERS AND
PROPERTY BASE WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATE BUT THE VERY SMALL
BUDGET WE HAVE IN AND MODE AND
THE BUSINESSES HATE THAT THIS.
S. BECAUSE IT'S ANOTHER TAX.
BUT MOST OF THE I THINK SEVENTY
OR 75% OF OURS VERY SMALL BUDGET.
GOES TO WHAT MOST PEOPLE
PERCEIVE ARCH CITY SERVICES LIKE
PICKING UP THE TRASH TRIMMING
THE TREES OR WASHING THE
SIDEWALKS.
SO I MEAN WE CAN'T USE OUR FUNDS --
TO DO THE THINGS THAT WE SHOULD
DO TO HELP PROMOTE THE SMALL
BUSINESSES WITH MARKETING AND
AND OTHER PROGRAMS ALL OF IT
GOES TO THINGS THAT MOST PEOPLE
THINK.
THE CITY DOESN'T HEAR HIM WOULD
MEAN THE CITY DOESN'T HAVE THAT
IS LIKE NO THE CITY OF LA DOES
NOT.
DO THAT IT IN LOS FELIS IF YOU
WANNA -- IN
LOS OUT LOS ANGELES BE ONE TO
GET YOU TREES TRIMMED IN THE
COMMERCIAL DISTRICT.
IT'S FIFTEEN YEARS YOU HAVE TO
WAIT -- SO
WILL WILL SPEND TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON TRIMMING TREES YOU
KNOW LOS FELIS VILLAGE.
I RIGHT THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO SAY
I'M JUST SO HAPPY I CAME --
I'M GONNA REPEAT BE REPORTING
BACK TO THE BED ON SOME OF THE
THINGS I LEARNED HERE AND ID
LIKE TO STAY IN TOUCH WITH
OTHERS --
DOT A MEASURE TODAY REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE TIME.
YOU FOR COMING THANK YOU AND
THANKS FOR YOUR COMMUNITY WORK
THAT ALLEGES A REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT PART OF THE FABRIC OF THE
COMMUNITIES [INAUDIBLE]
YOU [INAUDIBLE]
ANYBODY ELSE [INAUDIBLE]
NOBODY --
WELL THEN I'LL MOVE TO CLOSING
COMMENTS --
ISRAEL'S YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING.
I JUST WANT TO THANK THOSE WHO
CAME FROM THE STATE TO PROVIDE A
SEPARATION.
I APPRECIATE THE GOLDMAN SACHS.
PROGRAM AS WELL AND I KNOW SOME
OF OUR BUSINESSES ALL ENCOURAGE
THEM TO LOOK INTO THAT.
MOST ESPECIALLY WANT TO THANK
THE SMALL BUSINESSES FOR BEING
HERE.
IT'S SO SO IMPORTANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU --
WHETHER YOU'VE BEEN HERE FOR A
SHORT WHILE YOU'RE CLOSING YOUR
DOORS OR YOU'VE BEEN HERE FOR A
LONG TIME TO PROVIDING
INTERNATIONAL SERVICES.
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU [INAUDIBLE]
I I IF WE DON'T HEAR FROM YOU
AGAIN WE ARE MAKING OUR
DECISIONS IN A VACUUM.
YES WE HAVE SMALL BUSINESS
EXPERIENCE --
FAMILY EXPERIENCES BECAUSE WE
OWN AURA FAMILIES OWN SMALL
BUSINESSES.
BUT AS THESE.
BILLS ARE BEING INTRODUCED WE DO
WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU.
AND EACH OF OUR OFFICES NOT ONLY
IN OUR OFFICES BUT OTHER --
OTHER OF OUR OUR COLLEAGUES
OFFICES THEY DO HAVE PEOPLE IN
THE OFFICE WERE GOING TO LISTEN
TO THE STERN.
AND MAKE SURE THAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OR THE SENATOR KNOWS OF
THE CONCERNS OF THE SMALL
BUSINESSES.
WE DO NEED TO HEAR YOU WE NEED
TO HEAR FROM YOU BECAUSE YOU ARE
THE CONSTITUENTS --
HOUSE ARE THE HOMEOWNERS AS OUR
THAT THE SOFTBALL PLAYERS IN
THIS THOSE IN SPORTS.
YOUR ALL OUR CONSTITUENTS WHO WE
NEED TO HEAR FROM YOU SO THAT
WHEN WE MAKE DECISIONS AND WE WE
TAKE OUR VOTES THEY ARE INFORMED
VOTES.
AND DURING THE PROCESS OF THE
COMMITTEE HEARINGS WERE ABLE TO
OFFER.
AMENDMENTS WERE ALL ABLE TO
OFFER COMMENTS SO THAT THE OFF
AUTHOR OF THE BILL CAN ALSO
CONSIDER THOSE CONCERNS ARE
BROUGHT TO US BY OUR
CONSTITUENTS SO AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU. FOR PROVIDING
YOUR INPUT.
I WANT -- TO
ALSO THANK EVERYONE WHO CAME AND
ALSO I THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES FOR DRIVING IN ALL THE WAY
FROM SAN BERNADINO COUNT TO BE
WITH US HERE TODAY --
BICU WHEN IT CAME FROM LONG
BEACH TO FROM ALL OVER THE AREA.
I WILL SAY THAT --
THE SMALL BUSINESSES DO HAVE
VOICES WITH THE LOCAL CHAMBERS
WITHIN THIS AREA WITH BIZ FED
AND VIKA.
AND THESE ARE GROUPS THAT ARE IN
OUR OFFICE AND INTERACTING WITH
US ON THE OTHER ASSEMBLY IN.
QUITE OFTEN SO IF YOU DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE REACHING OUT
DIRECTLY TO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS I
HOPE YOU DO FEEL COMFORTABLE BUT
THOSE THOSE GROUPS ARE ALSO
AVAILABLE IN THE MEAT.
ALL THE TIME AND THEY OFFER
GREAT NETWORKING I'M
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PEOPLE IN THEY
ALSO DO ADVOCATE ON ISSUES THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO REGIONAL --
BUSINESS GROUPS BECAUSE MONTHS
IT VARIES IF YOU'RE IN LOS
ANGELES THAT'S A WHOLE SET OF
ISSUES THAT MIGHT BE DIFFERENT
FROM GLENDALE THAT.
ACTUALLY TRIMS THE TREES AND AND
AND DOES YOU KNOW PROVIDES
DIFFERENT SERVICES SO SOMETIMES
DIFFERENT BUSINESSES.
HOW DIFFERENT OBSTACLES IN
DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES BASED ON
WHERE THEY ARE A BUT THIS IS
REALLY HELPFUL AND FOR ME IT'S
THE BEGINNING OF --
WELCOME THE CONTINUATION OF A
DIALOGUE THAT WE'VE BEEN
ENGAGING WITH OUR SMALL BUSINESS
COMMUNITY SINCE COMING INTO
OFFICE BUT THERE WERE SOME
REALLY SOLID.
OPPORTUNITIES HERE AND AND I'M
INFORMATION HERE THAT I HOPE
THAT.
OUR SMALL BUSINESS COMMUNITY
WATCHES BECAUSE WE'VE HEARD FROM
MY BUSINESS WHO DIDN'T KNOW
ABOUT A LOT OF WHAT'S ON
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE STATE AND
THROUGH THE COUNTY SO IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE ALL
PUSH THAT OUT THEM GLAD THE
PRESS IS HERE.
MEN CAN HELP MAYBE PUT SOME OF
THAT INFORMATION OUT TO THE
COMMUNITY --
BUT ALSO THE CHALLENGES THAT
COME UP THAT ARE GROWING
CHALLENGES AND SOME OF THEM ARE
HUGE THINGS LIKE WORKERS COMP
I'D LOVE TO GO IN REFORM WORKERS
COMPLEMENT EXTERIOR.
I'LL BE REALISTIC.
WE MIGHT HAVE THAT AS A LONG
TERM GOAL IT'S PROBABLY NOT
GONNA HAPPEN IN SIX MONTHS OR A
YEAR.
BUT OTHER THINGS ARE DEFINITELY --
OF MORE IMMEDIATE IN TERMS
PENDING WHAT.
SO IT'S REALLY GREAT TO HEAR
ABOUT THAT AND THEN SOME OF THE
SUGGESTIONS LIKE MAKING SURE
THIS A SMALL BUSINESS ON THE
FILM COMMISSION IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN GO IN AND TRY TO
HAVE AN IMPACT ABOUT IS THOSE
POSITIONS OPEN UP --
HEARING ABOUT.
I'M THE PROCUREMENT ISSUES AND
ABOUT CONTRACTS THAT --
SP ONE SAYS SHOULD BE LOCAL
CONTRACTS AND MAYBE LOOKING INTO
THAT AND HAVING SOME OVERSIGHT
AND SAYING IS THAT REALLY BEING
DONE.
HOW IS THAT DONE --
THESE ARE ALL REALLY --
THE SOLITAIRE CRIMES FROM TODAY.
LIKE I SAID WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
ANOTHER ONE OF THESE --
SMALL BUSINESS MEETINGS ON THE
CENTRAL COAST AND I WAS JUST
TOLD THAT WE HAVE A REQUEST FROM
ONE SAMPLE TO DENOUNCE.
WILL TRY TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN AND
YOU KNOW TALK TO SOME OF THE
FOLKS OUT THERE ABOUT SOME OF
THEIR ISSUES.
SO AGAIN I THINK EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING THIS IS JUST
BEGINNING OF OF YOU KNOW THIS
DIALOGUE AND I REALLY APPRECIATE
ALL THE PARTICIPATION WE HAD
TODAY.
THANKS SO MUCH